ce matin les auditions de la mission
d'information que notre commission a
décidé de constituer sur la création du
fond Marianne la sélection des projets
subventionnés le contrôle de leur
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes nous entendons
donc ce matin dans ce cadre monsieur
Sébastien Jallet préfet de l'Orne en sa
qualité d'anciens directeurs de cabinet
de Madame Marlène Schiappa ministre
délégué auprès du ministre de
l'Intérieur chargé de la citoyenneté
comme vous le savez nous avons entendu
ces dernières semaines le secrétaire
général du cipdr monsieur Christian
Gravel ainsi que les représentants de
plusieurs associations ayant bénéficié
des crédits du fond Marianne nous
attendons donc de votre audition que
vous puissiez nous préciser la manière
dont à vos fonctions vous avez suivi ce
dossier en lien d'une part avec la
ministre et d'autre part avec les
services ministériels
avant de vous céder la parole pour un
bref propos introductif on s'est mis
d'accord comme vous êtes seul sur une
dizaine de minutes maximum je dois vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
une commission d'enquête et passible de
sanctions pénales qui peuvent aller
selon les circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à 100.000
euros d'amende
je vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levez la main droite et dites je le jure
je le jure
je vous laisse maintenant Monsieur le
Préfet
là par le président monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
les sénateurs je remercie la commission
de m'entendre aujourd'hui et nous donner
l'occasion d'apporter ma part
d'explication aux questions
intéressantes la gestion du fond
Marianne j'ai été auditionné par la
mission de contrôle de l'inspection
géant de l'administration diligenté par
le ministère de l'Intérieur
je serai logiquement entendu dans le cas
de l'information judiciaire ouverte par
le parquet national financier j'ai été
sollicité par les médias et je n'ai pas
souhaité y donner suite réservant mes
réponses aux organismes et institutions
cette audition par votre commission
d'enquête revête donc pour moi
l'importance particulière car elle est
sans doute la seule occasion qui me soit
donnée de tenir une parole publique sur
le fond Marianne et plus globalement sur
le sens et les modalités du contre
discours républicain
comme vous l'avez mentionné monsieur le
Président je suis préfet de l'Orne et
avant cela j'ai été directeur de cabinet
de la ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de l'Intérieur chargé de la
citoyenneté à compter du 3 septembre
2020 et jusqu'au 31 janvier 2022 dans
cette responsabilité
j'étais chargé comme le son
classiquement les directeurs de Cannes
des membres du gouvernement
de plusieurs missions d'abord de manager
l'équipe du Cabinet composé de 12
collaborateurs auprès de la ministre
délégué ensuite d'assister la ministre
dans la définition de sa feuille de
route de ses orientations stratégiques
de piloter
la mise en oeuvre avec les
administrations placées sous l'autorité
de la ministre remise à sa disposition
qui était diverses
et j'assurai une fonction de liaison
avec les autres ministères et avec
Matignon sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
j'étais au sein du cabinet le seul à
bénéficier d'une délégation de
signatures de la ministre déléguée et
donc le seul à pouvoir
valablement légalement juridiquement
engagé la décision ministérielle dans un
rapport de loyauté et de confiance entre
la ministre et moi-même
cette fonction générale de coordination
je l'exercer sur l'ensemble des champs
relevant des attributions de la ministre
déléguée elle était en charge d'un
ministère nouvellement créé le ministère
délégué à la citoyenneté auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur avec les
attributions
importantes et d'une grande diversité il
me paraît important de les mentionner en
quelques en quelques termes ces
attributions recouvraient
schématiquement deux grands domaines
tout d'abord la protection des Français
avec les attributions confiées à la
ministre déléguée pour la prévention de
la délinquance pour la prévention de la
radicalisation la lutte contre la dérive
sectaire
la mise en oeuvre des engagements du
Grenoble des violences conjugales pour
ce qui concerne l'action des forces de
sécurité intérieure lutte contre le
séparatisme
la deuxième ligue de force dans les
attributions de la ministre avait très à
aux valeurs de la République avec la
promotion de l'engagement citoyen la
politique de l'asile et d'accueil des
réfugiés la politique de l'intégration
naturalisation le déploiement de la
nouvelle carte nationale d'identité
électronique et le portage
interministériel de la laïcité
j'étais en tant que directeur de cabinet
en charge de préparer et d'exécuter les
décisions de la ministre sous l'ensemble
de ces de ces champs et je m'attachais à
et je m'attacher à y accorder une
importance égale
quel que soit les sujets les dossiers
j'ai ainsi naturellement été en prise
avec la mise en place d'une action
nouvelle de contre des cours
républicains et avec la mise la mise en
place du fond du fond Marianne
je souhaiterais avant de répondre à vos
questions pouvoir replacer en quelques
mots cette démarche dans son dans son
contexte
ce contexte c'est d'abord la veille dans
un terroriste qui frappe le pays à
l'automne 2020 avec le 25 septembre
l'attentat de la rue Nicolas Appert
devant l'ancien siège de Charlie Hebdo
l'attentat d'eragny-sur-oise le 16
octobre 2020
l'attentat la basilique de Nice le 27 le
29 octobre 2020 et ses attentats place
plus que jamais les pouvoirs publics
dans une ardente obligation d'agir et de
protéger dans tous les domaines
ce contexte c'est donc aussi celui d'une
mobilisation générale contre la haine en
ligne contre le cyber islamisme contre
les idées séparatistes sur Internet
lesquels portent en germe chez certains
individus des risques de bascule dans la
radicalisation et la violence terroriste
la création du fond Marianne s'inscrit
dans ce contexte et n'est que l'un des
éléments d'une stratégie d'ensemble
arrêtée en conseil de défense et de
sécurité nationale à l'automne 2020 et
qui se déploie dans plusieurs directions
il y a d'abord le renforcement de la
plateforme dite Pharos opéré par des
policiers et des gendarmes de la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire une plateforme qui traite les
signalements de contenu à licite sur sur
internet pour à la fois imprimer les
auteurs et demander le retrait de ces
contenus auprès des opérateurs il est
décidé et le ministre de l'Intérieur la
ministre délégué mettre en place le
dispositif de renforcer sensiblement la
plateforme Pharos en portant ses
effectifs de 30 policiers gendarmes à 54
en quelques mois pour assurer un
fonctionnement H24 c'est-à-dire 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 il renforcer
la capacité à judiciariser les contenus
haineux illicitent sur internet en
obtient le retrait auprès des opérateurs
c'est aussi dans cette stratégie la
création en janvier 2021 du pôle
national contre la haine en ligne au
sein du parquet de Paris pour renforcer
la réponse pénale face aux affaires les
plus graves ou les plus complexes une un
engagement qui bien sûr relève du garde
des sceaux de la Chancellerie mais qui
fait partie de ces stratégie d'ensemble
portées par le gouvernement cette
pratique est aussi des dispositions de
loi
adoptées dans la loi confortant le
respect des principes de la République
pour tout d'abord
renforcer les obligations des
plateformes dans la suppression des
sites du miroirs des sites qui
répliquent les contenus interdits par la
justice
les plateformes devant désormais assuré
leur effacement véritable ainsi que le
des référencement de ces de ces sites
c'est aussi le principe de la
comparaison immédiate introduite par la
loi pour les auteurs d'infraction les
plus graves en matière de n en ligne tel
que de négationnisme
ou d'incitation à la haleine et à la
violence
c'est aussi une disposition de loi qui
crée un délit de mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui par diffusion
d'informations personnelles sur Internet
dans la tension de nuire en référence
direct aux agissements dont on était
victime
plusieurs plusieurs personnes et le
professeur de confiance en Honorine en
particulier avec un délit puni de 3 ans
d'emprisonnement 45000 euros d'amende et
des sanctions qui sont majorées si elles
touchent une personne dépositote des
postures de l'autorité publique ou
chargée d'une mission de service public
c'est stratiste c'est une mobilisation
au niveau communautaire pour renforcer
la législation européenne avec
l'adoption du règlement dit TCO contre
les contenus terroristes en 2021 qui
oblige l'état de forme à supprimer en
moins d'une heure les contenus à
caractère terroriste ou les efforts
déployés par la France pour promouvoir
le projet de directive digital service
et c'est aussi cette stratégie la mise
en place d'une action nouvelle de
contrediscours républicain il y a bien
une stratégie d'ensemble laquelle sera
d'ailleurs érigée au rang de réforme
prioritaire du gouvernement à la fin de
2020 elle fait partie des 73 réformes
prioritaires du gouvernement elle est
confiée aux ministres de l'Intérieur à
la ministre délégué en termes de
coordination même si elle associe
d'autres ministère je pense à la
Chancellerie mais ça va juste en
particulier
au ministère chargé du numérique et les
ministres seront amenés régulièrement à
rendre compte de l'avancement de cette
stratégie en conseil des ministres ce
sera notamment le 12 janvier 2022 avec
une communication sur les réformes
prioritaires du ministère d'intérieur
dans laquelle la ministre délégué
des avancées des progrès des enjeux en
matière du contrôle en ligne et le et le
cyber islamisme merci Monsieur le Préfet
si vous voulez bien qu'on en reste là je
pense qu'à l'occasion les
questionnements qui vont venir vous
aurez l'occasion éventuellement de
repréciser quelques points merci de nous
avoir fait en tout cas un rappel
utile sur à la fois le contexte que nous
connaissions de manière générale si je
puis dire mais en rappelant que la
création de ce format donc fait partie
d'une stratégie plus globale ce que vous
nous présentez ce matin merci beaucoup
nous en venons pour notre part nous
restons vous connaissez évidemment le
rôle de notre mission et elle est
aujourd'hui cernée sur l'élaboration
d'abord dans un premier temps du fond
Marianne donc vous nous avez décrit le
contexte général le fait que le fond
Marianne est un élément parmi d'autres
ce que nous comprenons bien
le fond Marianne et ces quelques moyens
et même le sujet même ne peuvent seul à
lui seul en tout cas répondre à une
question aussi large que celle que vous
avez rappelé mais plus spécifiquement
pouvez-vous nous dire d'où vient l'idée
finalement de mettre en place ce fond et
qui a l'idée de l'appeler pour mariage
et finalement d'en faire un lien avec
le professeur assassiné
oui
[Musique]
la création du fond Bryan s'inscrit dans
ce dans ce contexte et dans ce cadre
dès l'automne 2020 il est donc acté par
les instances compétentes la mise en
place d'une action de contre discours
contre discours républicain pardon juste
les instances compétentes alors je
faisais référence au Conseil de défense
et de sécurité nationale qui a adopté la
stratégie d'ensemble contre la haine en
ligne et le cyber islamisme et le
principe d'une action de contrediscours
républicain c'est ainsi dans cette
stratégie et valider par cet instant à
l'automne 2020
cette démarche s'inspire pour partie de
ce que les Britanniques ont mis en place
depuis 2007 en créant le
Riku
le riz search une formation une
communication unit par donner mon accent
une unité constituée au sein du
homophisme pour porter des actions de
contreditours avec à la fois un contre
discours institutionnel porté par une
structure d'État et un contre discours
sociétal porté par des acteurs
associatifs
et la démarche que nous mettons en place
à l'automne 2020 s'inspire pour partie
de cet exemple britannique et selon ce
schéma
à deux axes un contre discours
institutionnel qui sera
très rapidement organisé au ministère
intérieur au sein du cipdr avec la
création de l'unité de contrediscours
républicain qui est armé dès novembre
2020 avec de première mise à disposition
puis aux personnes en puissance sur le
début de 2021 l'unité contrat une
quinzaine d'agents en avril 2021 donc
pour Marianne est lancé et une vingtaine
d'agents à la fin 2021
l'autre c'est le conseil de défense on
est à quelle date on est fait octobre on
est fantôme
on est dès après les attentats qui
frappe la France donc le conseil de
défense dit il faut mettre en place un
fond alors une action de contreditours
républicains
laquelle comprend deux démarches une
démarche institutionnelle la structure
d'État quantité au sein du cipdr et une
démarche sociétale d'implication des
acteurs associatifs
cette démarche de contour des sources
sociétales elle est donc initiée de
l'automne 2020 elle prend appui par
ailleurs sur des expériences sur des
acquis qui sont plus anciens puisque des
2014-2015 il y a au cipdr et au-delà la
volonté d'accompagner la société civile
dans la réaction à l'islamisme c'est pas
encore l'initiative stop djihadisme
porté par le
Service d'information du gouvernement
que diriger le préfet Christian Gravel à
l'époque ce sont aussi des actions qui
sont inscrites dans le plan national de
prévention de la radicalisation de 2018
il y a donc depuis déjà plusieurs années
la volonté de promouvoir un contour
discours sociétal mais là il s'agit de
changer d'échelle
et d'agir
vite et fort
pour cela
pour agir en matière de construction
sociétale il faut concrètement un budget
et des partenaires associatifs
le budget c'est assez naturellement le
fond interministériel pour la promotion
de la dame en vacances le FIPD qui a
vocation en constitué le support
nous sommes fin 2020
la loi de finances pour 2021 à reconduit
le SIPD à son niveau de 2020 à 69
millions d'euros
une fois prise en compte la réserve de
précaution il reste 66 millions d'euros
au sein du FIPD et le constat qui est
formé très vite par la ministre et par
moi-même c'est que le JPD n'est pas en
capacité de financer des actions
nouvelles de contrefu républicain au
niveau où on l'ambitionne sur ces 66
millions d'euros il y a des dépenses qui
sont incompressibles en tout cas nous
les apprécions ainsi ce sont les 54
millions d'euros de crédit qui sont
déconcentrés au préfet pour financer des
actions de proximité dans les
territoires de prévention de la
délinquance prévention de la
radicalisation dépend de la
vidéoprotection nous estimons ces
dépenses incompressibles
il y a également le programme dit k
de sécurisation des sites sensibles et
des lieux de culte 4 millions d'euros
que nous estimons également un
compressible et d'ailleurs en gestion
2021 nous allons majorer ce programme de
1 million d'euros supplémentaire il
reste donc 8 millions d'euros au niveau
au sein du FIPD 8 millions d'euros qui
sont gérés au niveau national et qui
sont également en forte tension puisque
nous devons et par redéploiement
financer sur cette enveloppe deux appels
à projets que la ministre en tant qu'en
conduire des appels à projets sur des
matières qui sont nouvelles pour le FIP
et la lutte contre
la lutte contre les atteintes à la
dignité humaine
c'est à dire la polygamie les mariages
forcés les syndicats de virginité en
référence à des dispositions inscrites
dans le projet de loi confortant le
respect des principes de la République
donc un four à terminer qui est très
contraint et qui n'a pas
la ressource pour financer même par
redéploiement des actions de
contreditours numérique il faut me
trouver des moyens nouveaux
supplémentaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous militons nous ferraillons
pour obtenir un report de crédit de 2020
sur 2021 afin de doter le type aidé
d'une enveloppe
suffisante pour financer le compte
facebook républicain nous obtenons sur
le mitraille du Premier ministre son
cabinet
une décision de report de 4 millions
d'euros
début 2021
c'est 4800000 euros ils vont être
affectés à deux priorités ministérielles
le contrediscours républicain pour
2.500000 euros et le développement de la
vidéoprotection dans un contexte où les
contrats de sécurité intégrée se mettent
en place il appelle les engagements
contractuels de la part de l'État sur la
vidéoprotection avec des dépenses pour
le type des plus importantes les
arbitrages rendus par le ministère de la
ministre délégué sont d'affecter ces
crédits de report à parité ou presque
entre vidéoprotection et contre des
secours républicains
donc si les crédits du fond Marianne
sont bien des crédits ordinaires du FIPD
ils ont procédé d'un abondement du fond
par report de crédit et sur arbitrage du
cabinet du premier ministre pour
2.500000 euros et ce montant est acquis
début 2021
deuxième condition réunir pour lancer un
contre discours sociétal avoir des
partenaires associatifs
nous entreprenons quand je le dis nous
aussi de cabinet de la ministre délégué
et le cipdr de rencontrer dès l'automne
2020 des acteurs associatifs qui sont
déjà connus ou qui se sont distingués
pour leur action ou leur réflexion en
matière de contreditours sociétal qu'il
s'agisse de porter la riposte contre les
campagnes d'influence ou de programme
séparatistes en ligne ou de promouvoir
toujours sur Internet la valeur de la
République et nous allons
le plus souvent ensemble d'ailleurs
cabinet d'administration c'est des
consignes que je passe à mes
collaborateurs d'administration vous
voyez ensemble des porteurs de projets
potentiellement intéressant et intéressé
pour mesurer leur capacités à entrer sur
des actions de contredifaux républicains
et c'est rencontres ces auditions ces
réunions ont avoir lieu de l'automne
2020 jusqu'à le printemps 2021
je réponds à pas l'occasion de voir deux
acteurs associatifs à mon niveau avant
le lancement du fond Marianne et mes
collaborateurs environ un nombre
important j'en ai pas la liste précise
mais il y a plusieurs associations
connues ou identifiées qui sont reçus
ces deux associations que vous voyez
c'est lesquels vous pouvez les citer
vous m'avez indiqué que vous souhaitez
citer des associations qui étaient déjà
connues peut-être pas d'autres ces
deux-là qui n'ont pas été jusqu'à
présent les travaux de la commission
mentionnée je ne souhaite pas pour des
raisons de protection de ces acteurs
associatifs sur un champ qui est un
champ exposant l'émotion de manière
publique je peux faire bien sûr à huis
clos vous communiquez après l'audition
la qualité de ces deux associations que
j'ai rencontré à mon niveau donc entre
fin 2020 début 2021 et mes
collaborateurs
vous avez dit tout à l'heure automne
2020 printemps 2021 moi je voudrais des
si vous pouviez avoir des dates plus
précises parce que ça nous amène de
septembre à juin c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose que de novembre à mars
puisque en 2021 le font Marianne vous
voyez ce que je veux dire alors les
rencontres audition avec les acteurs
associatifs ou les intellectuels
impliqués
en matière de contre discours débute en
novembre
et s'achève début avril lorsque les
sillons est prise de lancer l'appel à
projet
il y a donc un certain nombre
d'associations qui vont des avants
lancement de l'appel à projet et même
avant qu'on le décide de lancer l'appel
à projet déposé auprès du cipdr à notre
invitation des demandes de subvention de
manière classique on est sur la gestion
du FIPD dans le régime juridique de la
subvention avec des décisions qui sont
discrétionnaires qui n'en sont pas moins
des décisions réfléchies motivées après
instruction administrative mais qui sont
des décisions discrétionnaires et il y a
donc des février 2021 ma connaissance de
prélèvement de subventions qui sont qui
sont déposés on reviendra monsieur on
reviendra Monsieur le Préfet vous le
comprenez vous avez utilisé le terme de
motivation bon
motivation
en tout cas qui n'apparaît dans aucun
document voilà donc peut-être qu'il y a
des motivations internes c'est ce que
vous indiquez mais il n'y a aucune
motivation
dans les documents que l'on nous a
transmis mais on y reviendra donc en
tout cas on retient l'idée toute simple
finalement mais sur laquelle on était
arrivé que il y a un travail sur le FIP
des traditionnel voilà PDR d'ailleurs
traditionnel avec une enveloppe Bron il
y a des projections déposées
traditionnellement il y a des
sollicitations qui sont faites vers des
associations connues du cipdr et qui
très logiquement
réfléchissent à un projet avec une
orientation vous me dites le trompe avec
une orientation plus comment dire sur
le commentaire le travail en ligne
comment on répond informatiquement
voilà comment comment on utilise les un
peu mieux les réseaux voilà et on en est
là quand on arrive vers la réflexion de
la création du fond Marianne donc je
reviens toujours vers cette question à
quel moment à quel moment et qui décide
de d'appeler finalement
de faire en sorte qui est une
appellation différenciée qu'on ne dise
pas tout simplement c'est le fipdr on
aurait pu avoir une communication très
simple en disant nous renforçons comment
dire les moyens du fipdr nous mettons en
place des moyens supplémentaires qui
permettront de faire ceci cela pourquoi
passe-t-on par finalement une
appellation que Monsieur Gravel
d'ailleurs dénommé comme un label de
communication je reprends exactement ces
termes que j'ai sous les yeux donc à
quel moment et qui décide de finalement
créer quelque chose qui aurait pu être
tout simple et en faire quelque chose
d'un peu plus complexe
et pourquoi
alors la décision de procéder par appel
à projet avec la création du fond du
Marianne elle est prise début avril
début avril je rattache cette décision à
une réunion que j'ai avec le ministre
début avril je crois que c'était le 7
avril à l'issue de laquelle nous
décidons conjointement nous en informons
à l'issue le cabinet puis
d'administration de procéder par appel à
projet et cette décision elle est prise
à mon sens pour deux raisons
la première c'est que nous faisons le
constat début avril après avoir pendant
4 à 5 mois
rencontrés reçus audition des électeurs
associatifs que nous avons nous sommes
toutes peu de projets associatifs
potentiellement
déposé pour porter le contre discours
sociétal j'y reviendrai
et que l'appel à projet est une manière
pertinente de susciter davantage de
projets et de partenariat le deuxième
motif de cette décision c'est un enjeu
de visibilité la ministre souhaite
donner de la visibilité à cette démarche
de contrediscours qui
avec le lancement du fond Marianne je ne
saurais pas vous dire d'où vient
l'appellation qui l'a proposé
je n'ai pas souvenir je n'ai pas de
trace numérique dans mes archives des
discussions de l'ont conduit à choisir
ce terme-là en tout cas le 7 avril on
décide de procéder par rappel à projet
et l'appellation fond Marianne vient
rapidement après le fond one c'est
effectivement à label c'est vrai
comme ça c'est un label
c'est aussi un préciput je raconte
budgétaire une enveloppe de 2500000
euros qui est
identifié qui est fléchée qui est
réservé au sein du FIPD pour financer le
contrôle discours sociétal en ligne en
ligne ainsi beaucoup là-dessus le
Président on est sur la volonté de
soutenir un contre discours en ligne et
pas en général
ce qui se faisait déjà précédemment sur
des actions de formation des acteurs la
conception de maître pédagogique ou
autre on veut agir en ligne sur les
réseaux sociaux
est prise le 7 avril
elle fait elle est communiquée
à l'ensemble du cabinet
à l'administration et le 13 avril
nous avons c'est un mardi nous avons
chaque mardi rien de coordination entre
l'état-major du cipdr et le cabinet
ministériel des réunions que je préside
chaque mardi
où nous allons les orientations et les
actions et donc le 13 avril je fais part
formellement au cipdr de la volonté
d'agir par rapport à projet et je
demande aussi PDR de préparer un texte
pour cet appel à projet en vue d'un
lancement le 20 avril
avec une communication de la ministre
qui s'opérera ce jour-là le 20 avril
est-ce que vous voulez dire qu'avant le
13 avril le cpdr à blanc ne travaille
pas déjà un appel d'offres il n'a pas
été sollicité il apprend le 13 avril
qu'il va y avoir un appel d'offre
il en est informé officiellement lors de
la réunion de coordination du 11 avril
il y avait
je pense des discussions préalables
depuis plusieurs semaines voire
davantage pour choisir le bon vecteur
la procédure classique d'une procédure
discrétionnelle de gras gré
sur laquelle le
IPD a fonctionné intégralement pendant
plusieurs années
ou l'appel à projet et dans les
discussions qu'on peut avoir des
discussions qui sont des discussions
enfin informées des discussions entre le
secrétaire général moi-même les membres
du cabinet les annonces peuvent être en
général j'ai pas de souvenirs très
précis et j'ai pas de traces écrites
dans mes archives et nous avons
nécessairement abordé ces questions le
choix du vecteur entre deux possibilités
et nous étions jusqu'en avril
sur la prise en modalité qui est la plus
classique la plus courante qui est le
gras gré de manière discrétionnaire et
si nous changeons d'orientation c'est
pour les deux raisons que je vous ai
mentionnées avoir davantage de personnes
associatifs et donner de la visibilité à
la démarche très bien on entend ça
quelle différence vous faites entre le
gré à gré et l'appel à projet tel qu'il
a été fait finalement puisque cet appel
à projet n'a donné lieu encore une fois
aucune grille de notation
je veux dire quand on regarde les choses
on est très proche du créateur en
réalité résultat
est-ce que quelle est la différence que
vous voyez entre la pratique de cet
appel à projet et le gré à gris
alors moi je vois plusieurs plusieurs
différences
la première et la principale me
semble-t-il c'est que l'appel à projet
comporte par construction une dimension
d'ouverture
et d'appel à candidature
avec un texte d'appel à projet qui
précise les attendus
qui précise le cadre
l'objet avec vous aime se le président
deux grandes actions qui sont éligibles
dans le cadre de l'appel à projet la
riposte
a
la propagande séparatiste en ligne ou la
promotion vers de la République des
critères qui sont précisés un dossier à
déposer qui est normé il y a des
éléments qui sont inscrits dans le test
de l'appel à projet sur les pièces
attendues pour pouvoir candidater donc
il y a une démarche je dirais à la fois
d'ouverture et de transparence sur le
cadre le critère et calendrier première
caractéristique distinctive de l'appel à
projet par rapport par rapport au gré à
gré
la seconde
je pense c'est que sa place
de fait les candidats dans une démarche
d'équité plus importante que dans le
gras grec puisque tout à chacun peut
candidater
et que les critères de l'appréciation
sont connus ou précisés avant avant
sélection on retient on retient votre
définition on reverra point par point si
c'est rempli dans l'opération en
question
ce rapporteur
j'avoue que je j'ai besoin de précision
parce que j'ai parfois du mal à suivre
mais ça me paraît pas illogique puisque
je comprends qu'il y a quand même
une
[Musique]
confusion entre parfois l'administration
et le cabinet vous avez évoqué donc une
décision communiquée en interne
avez-vous dit le 13 avril
dans ce que vous appelez une réunion de
coordination jusqu'à maintenant
la journée du 13 peut-être vu plusieurs
réunions se succéder puisque jusqu'à
maintenant on a entendu parler d'un
comité de programmation or au regard de
la question que vient de vous poser le
président était les réunions de
coordination habituelle du mardi
et y a-t-il eu une autre réunion dite
comité de coordination antérieure où est
à ce moment-là évoqué le fond Marianne à
la réunion du vin voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez
éclairer ma notre lanterne
donc
le 13 avril si à la fois
le jour où se tient la réunion
hebdomadaire de coordination et c'est le
jour où nous mettons en place pour la
première fois je crois le comité de
programmation sur les crédits du FIPD
comité
dont la création
a été souhaitée et organisé pour
structurer des échanges jusque là
informels entre le cipdr et le cabinet
ministre sur les sujets budgétaires
c'est donc une seule et même réunion où
il y a deux réunions différentes c'est
un seul temps qui se décompose par une
sur une cuisse de compose en deux temps
un temps de programmation
budgétaire et un temps plus général et
ordinaire sur les autres sujets qui sont
nombreux que nous traitons avec le cipdr
donc programmation nous le mettons en
place ce jour là il sera amené à se
réunir autant que de besoin par la suite
sur les questions les questions
financières les questions budgétaires
c'est une démarche que j'ai souhaité
mettre en place et structurer pour
donner de la collégialité et de la
traçabilité dans le processus
décisionnel quant à l'emploi des crédits
budgétaires nous sommes dans un cadre
qui est un cadre qui se veut clair dans
la répartition des rôles
nous allons nous allons y revenir
Monsieur le Préfet
il nous a été indiqué à l'audition
qu'avec l'arrivée de la ministre délégué
madame Marlène Schiappa le 6 juillet
2020 le processus de décision du moins
pour l'attribution des subventions FIPD
était remontée du secrétariat général du
cpdr au cabinet cela nous a été indiqué
de manière comment dire un petit peu
imprécise d'abord par le secrétaire
général et de manière beaucoup plus
précise par le secrétaire général
adjoint qui indique que donc dès
l'arrivée de la ministre je fais simple
et dit un changement qu'il voit entre
Octobre et fin d'année où la décision ne
relève plus d'affectation qui était
traditionnellement une responsabilité du
secrétaire général devient une
responsabilité du cabinet est-ce que
vous confirmez
alors je ne sais pas comment les
décisions ont été
préparées et acter avant ma prise de
fonction nous prononcerait pas sur ce
point-là ce que je peux confirmer c'est
que il y a bien une volonté de la
ministre et du cabinet de pouvoir
décider valider l'emploi des crédits du
FIP aller tu ne les ministres sont
responsables des politiques publiques
sont amenés en rencontres devant leurs
internationale
autant que de que de besoin que
nécessaire il est légitime normal et
attendu que les ministres et la ministre
délégué décide de l'emploi des crédits
qu'elle a en responsabilité je me
permettrai pas monsieur le Président je
me permettrai pas Monsieur le Préfet de
parler de légitimité ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que l'antériorité n'est pas celle
là c'est à dire que l'antériorité c'est
en gros comme il est souvent le cas le
ministre donne une orientation le
cabinet fait en sorte que
l'administration suive l'orientation de
la ministre c'est bien le moins mais
lorsqu'il y a des procédures procédure
réglementaires lorsqu'il y a des appels
à projets ils sont en fait dans ce cas
comme très souvent dans l'administration
menée par l'administration et dans ce
cas précis par le secrétaire général du
CI PDF donc il y a bien mais vous nous
le confirmez
je mets en débat la question est-ce que
c'est légitime ce qui est légitime c'est
que la ministre voit sa politique
réalisée ça nous sommes d'accord mais
ensuite sur le travail de la ministre le
rôle de la ministre le rôle du cabinet
le rôle de l'administration là par
contre c'est un peu divergent et
d'ailleurs c'est une nouveauté qui est
d'ailleurs remarquée par tous les
salariés du civil d'ailleurs tous les
agents qui voilà un changement de modèle
si je puis dire dans la façon de décider
tout remonte au cabinet alors je
voudrais
un bruit que vous ayez sur ce point oui
mais je présente je voudrais peut-être
préciser les choses il faut aussi tenir
compte du fait que la ministre est en
charge d'un nouveau ministère délégué à
la citoyenneté qui recouvre pour la
première fois les missions du CIPR oui
bien au-delà mais c'est la première fois
que vous gouvernement est chargé d'un
carnet de portée la politique publique
de prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation dans l'architecture des
gouvernements la première fois et donc
la ministre a à cœur de pouvoir fixer
ses orientations de pouvoir
reprisoriser les choix budgétaires et
nous demandent de l'organiser en
conséquence nous le faisons de manière
claire c'est-à-dire que le rôle du
cabinet auprès de la ministre c'est un
rôle d'orientation vous l'avez vu ce
président d'orientation et de validation
mais pour ce qui est des subventions
nationales
le recueil des demandes
l'instruction des demandes
la proposition de financement relève
d'une phase administrative elle relève
du cipdr
de même que la phase amont de mise en
forme des conventions attributives de
subventions et de suivi relève également
de l'administration le cabinet dans ces
comités de programmation et dans un rôle
d'impulsion de validation pas dans un
rôle
d'instructions dans un rôle d'exécution
on est tout à fait d'accord mais si le
préfet mais
vous dites le mot je veux bien prendre
votre mot c'est pas on va dire
des décisions vous dites de validation
je voudrais dire que dans ce cas précis
c'est un synonyme c'est-à-dire que
l'administration propose le cabinet
dispose je fais simple et nous
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure avec le
rapporteur nous verrons quelques cas sur
lequel le cabinet est intervenu soit à
la hausse ou à la baisse et c'est une
intervention cabinet de manière très
claire mais nous vous le poserons mais
je voudrais à ce moment-là de notre
propos puisque depuis hier nous avons le
rapport d'inspection que notre collègue
caoutchi a indiqué tout à l'heure
relatif donc à la subvention versée à
l'uspm dans le cadre il faut Marianne ce
rapport d'inspection du coup comment
dire
pose une question très forte et je
dirais même qu'il le met
en point numéro 1 de ces conclusions
l'enquête de l'inspection de
l'administration de l'igéa aboutit à un
ensemble de conclusions en se limitant à
trois recommandations je vais vous lire
la première
l'appel à projet n'a été ni transparent
ni équitable
alors je mets ça en lien avec le rôle du
cabinet justement sur cet appel à projet
on vient d'indiquer et vous l'avez
confirmé
que le cabinet était en responsabilité
de choix de validation vous avez indiqué
à partir de propositions du cellulaire
aucun doute mais c'est vous qui avez
validé
l'inspection générale d'administration
vous dit que vous avez validé un appel à
projet qui n'a été ni transparent ni
équitable
les mots ont un sens
comment vous réagissez à cet élément
alors moi je n'ai pas d'observation
personnelle à porter sur le rapport de
l'IA quand on est préfet un rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration
on le lit on intègre ces recommandations
on les met en oeuvre on les commande pas
moi ce que je voudrais dire et par
rapport à votre promo je suis président
c'est qu'on a deux démarches le candid
est important on a deux démarches qui se
sont rejointes et chevauchés une
démarche qui court jusqu'au 13 avril où
on est sur la le choix de procéder de
manière discrétionnaire et de gré à gré
et à partir de 13 avril une autre
démarche qui sera une démarche d'appel à
projet nous avons le 13 avril en
commission plusieurs dossiers
qui sont présentés par le cipère parce
que dansait déjà déposé des demandes de
subvention
il y a il y a quatre dossiers qui sont
qui sont déposés et qui proposent des
actions de contrediscours numérique le
13 avril en commission le choix qui est
fait c'est de faire de reporter ces
dossiers sur l'appel à projet
et il n'y a pas de dossier
retenu dans le cadre de l'appel à projet
qui était décidé avant
l'appel à projet et transparent il y a
un texte appel à projet il est équitable
semble-t-il au sens où tous les
candidats et tous les lauréats auront vu
leur
subventions leur demande appréciées plus
tard dans le cadre de l'appel à projet
si vous voulez Monsieur le Préfet vous
vous sentez bien qu'il y a un petit
le rapporteur qui va point par point
voir un petit peu
qu'est-ce qui est sur la table alors
avant de lui donner la parole je vais je
vais terminer mais je pense que sur ce
sujet simplement de l'équité de la
transparence les auditions précédentes
que nous avons eu
ce qui est en général secrétaire général
adjoint
des associations
si on relève bien tout ce qui a été dit
par les uns par les autres sincèrement
lorsque j'ai lu ce matin ou hier soir
plus exactement que l'appel à projet n'a
été ni transparent ni équitable doit
vous dire que
peut-être qu'on verra ce qu'on écrira
dans notre propre rapport enfin c'est
pas quelque chose qui nous a tout à fait
tout à fait étonné on le verra on le
verra tout à l'heure
alors juste avant juste avant Monsieur
le Préfet on va y revenir vous inquiétez
pas c'est un sujet qui est important
le cabinet donc on va essayer de rentrer
dans ce dossier puisque c'est le seul
pour l'instant qui est d'ailleurs
regardé par l'Inspection Générale
d'administration on nous promet pour la
fin du mois un rapport un peu plus un
peu plus large mais on a si je puis dire
les presque les bonnes feuilles si je
puis dire du rapport final ou complet
sur sur un dossier qui est particulier
qui concerne donc une association
l'uspm et bien sûr apparaît dans ce dans
ce dossier Monsieur Mohamed Sifaoui qui
s'est d'ailleurs beaucoup exprimé dans
la presse contrairement à vous je dois
le dire et à nous qui ne l'avons pas
fait non plus sinon sous la forme de
conférence de presse et donc
je vais vous poser deux questions puis
je vais ouvrir le débat à mes collègues
d'abord sur le monsieur Mohammed syfaoui
j'ai exprimait dans la presse
en disant que en gros on est allé le
chercher excusez-moi cette formule là un
peu un peu lapidaire mais en tout cas
que le cabinet et la ministre et où
d'ailleurs lorsqu'il se présentera il
viendra nous préciser des choses
la contacter en sachant que Monsieur
Sifaoui avait déjà travaillé pour le
cpdr sur des questions de formation
semble-t-il donc est-ce que le cabinet a
eu oui ou non est-ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer des contacts avec
Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui antérieurement
à l'élaboration du fond Marianne et si
oui pouvez-vous nous préciser la teneur
de ces contacts
un acteur qui est connu qui fait
en quelque sorte références en matériaux
contre l'islamisme et le sidarislamisme
qui faisait déjà du contreditours
sociétal à travers ces réseaux sociaux
ou le site islamoscope qu'il avait créé
à titre personnel et à ce titre il a été
reçu par le Cami de la ministre et le
cipdr par vous même donc par le cabinet
de la ministre par vous-même ah non non
pas
mes collaborateurs au cabinet merci
notamment le Conseil spécial de la
ministre qui était en charge de
piloter les actions de contrediscours
avec d'autres membres du cabinet et le
cipdr à une ou plusieurs reprises je ne
serai pas le direct précision en tout
cas il a été reçu bien évidemment au
cabinet à sa demande
je saurais pas vous le dire je pense
qu'on l'a je pense qu'on l'a
solliciterait certainement très
certainement pour avoir un échange avec
lui sur sa vision des choses c'est sa
réflexion la façon dont il appréhende
l'enjeu du contrôle républicain qui est
une action publique nouvelle on est en
train
d'expérimenter d'innover on a besoin
d'élémentiers de réflexion collective de
rencontrer des acteurs des chercheurs
des scientifiques donc c'est une phase
de consultation assez intense
et la personne que vous avez cité va
début avril
présenté un projet alors là nous la nous
y revenons parce que nous aurons
effectivement la question sur la teneur
des différentes rencontres qu'il y a pu
avoir monsieur cifaoui dans un premier
temps donc on propose d'y revenir un peu
un peu plus loin
donc
Christian Gravel dit j'ai appris que
l'uspm pourrait bénéficier des fonds
Marianne lors d'un appel téléphonique de
Monsieur cifaoui donc ça vient pas par
le cabinet qu'on aurait pu imaginer mais
ça vient par Monsieur cifaoui qui sort
d'un rendez-vous nous dit-il avec la
ministre ou le cabinet on reste prudent
sur cela mais
que donc son implication son
investissement lui permettre de
prétendre à effectivement pouvoir
répondre donc quand est-ce que ce
rendez-vous a eu lieu
ce premier rendez-vous
je dépose sincèrement oui
la ministre n'a pas reçu Monsieur
cifaoui très bien à ma connaissance
pour le compte de la ministre
le 22 avril
à 15h15
au Canada ministre un rendez-vous qui
était organisé par par le scrutin perdu
de ministre pour qu'elle reçoive la
personne que vous avez cité également la
ministre n'a pas pu pour des raisons de
conflit d'agenda et d'urgence assurés
sur rendez-vous même et de la
représenter donc j'ai reçu et c'est le
seul rendez-vous que j'aurais avec motif
à oui sur ces questions là le 22 avril à
15h15
et je suis très clair et très précis sur
ce point mes collaborateurs au cabinet
de Me que le cipdr ont pu rencontrer
Monsieur Sifaoui à plusieurs reprises
précédemment très certainement
fin mars fin mars début avril également
il y a pu y avoir une il y a eu une
incitation une invitation à
envisager un projet associatif pour
recevoir un soutien
du cipdr et une fois que ce projet a eu
été communiqué et déposé je crois que
c'est le 9 avril c'est le cipdr dans ces
missions
administratives de gestion des banc de
subventions qui a géré l'entièreté de la
relation avec les porteurs de projet en
ce qui concerne on va y revenir
simplement
vous le savez le rapport de l'inspection
indique qu'il y a eu ces rencontres
entre mars et avril 2021 entre votre
cabinet de manière large il y en a une
avec vous mais c'est ainsi que c'est
indiqué dans le rapport de l'inspection
le rapport on se présente me semble-t-il
retranscrit les propos tenus par l'un
des protagonistes
en bas de page précise qu'elle n'est pas
en mesure de déterminer le
nombre de nature des raisons qui se sont
tenues on en tiendra compte on va faire
une petite pause avant de donner la
parole rapporteur avec quelques
questions de dessinateurs dans la salle
monsieur carucci
monsieur le Président d'abord
permettez-moi de dire je m'élève un
petit peu en agacement sur le
dialectique qui n'est pas celle de
Monsieur le Préfet mais ça m'agace un
peu d'entendre dire le contrediscours et
public maintenant c'est devenu un
formules à la mode comme si ceux d'en
face avait un discours républicain que
nous on avait un contre discours
républicain il y a un seul discours
républicain et il y a ceux qui ne l'ont
pas donc arrêtons de dire contre
discours c'est l'impression d'être dans
un débat avec d'autres qui ont une autre
acceptation la République qui n'a qu'une
seule acceptation de la République
deuxième élément Monsieur le Préfet moi
depuis le début de cette affaire je me
dis mais
expérience absolue les associations qui
ont été d'une manière ou d'une autre
associée au fond Marianne apporte de
plus que ne pouvait apporter les
structures publiques
il existe on en a vu des campagnes
organisées par le service d'intérêt d'un
service d'information du gouvernement
qui a quand même un budget d'une
quinzaine de millions d'euros qui
emploie 90 personnes il y a le cipdr qui
existe depuis 2006 qui emploie lui-même
une soixantaine de personnes
dans le fond est-ce que les associations
apportées une telle différence de
capacité de messages ou d'expérience
qu'on ne puisse pas passer que par les
structures publiques on a vu pendant un
certain nombre de problèmes la pandémie
ou autre des campagnes aussi bien
d'ailleurs dans les médias publics que
sur les réseaux sociaux qui étaient
plutôt bien faite et qui était fait
directement soit par les ministères soit
par les structures publiques est-ce que
réellement quand on voit les clips qu'on
a vu des associations est-ce que
réellement
les structures publiques étaient
incapables de faire ce genre de d'action
est-ce que réellement on considère que
les associations ont eu un plus
très différents très bénéfique par
rapport à ce qu'on aurait pu faire les
structures publiques
sur le préfet si en quelques mots vous
pouvez répondre à notre collègue
moi je vous rejoins je le disais il y a
deux modalités pour le contre discours
alors républicain c'est le discours de
la République comporte contre les emails
de la République c'est vrai que les
termes peuvent être
polysémiques ou ambium il y a deux
modalités le contre discours
institutionnel au grand discours
sociétal
nous mettons la priorité sur le contenu
discours institutionnel avec la création
dès novembre 2020 de l'unité de
contreditours au sein du cipdr
et je le précise un effort significatif
qui est porté puisque le Premier
ministre au Parlement l'automne 2020
annonce le renforcement des services du
ministère d'intérieur contre la ligne
cyber islamisme à hauteur de 100 ETTP
100 emplois et cette décision est
naturellement suivie des faits et c'est
ce qui permettra de renforcer les
effectifs de la plateforme Pharos de
renforcer les services de renseignement
de renforcer certaines préfectures
également et d'armée l'unité de
contredifaux républicain à hauteur de 35
ETP au sein du cpdr avec donc 20 UTP qui
sont mobilisés en 2021 et le seul qui
doit l'être par la suite donc la
priorité est bien mise y compris en
termes de choix budgétaire sur le
contredit discours institutionnel
lequel peut rencontrer aussi des limites
puisque c'est un contre discours qui
intervient sur compte public le compte
du cipdr le contré public
tirait tirez-vous donc un message public
qui se veut fort mais qui est un message
public et qui peut auprès de certains et
je pense auprès des jeunes parfois en
particulier être un discours qui a moins
de portée que s'il est
exprimé par des acteurs de la société
civile et nous éprouvons le besoin de
mobiliser la société civile d'avoir des
acteurs associatifs qui portent cette
parole sur le vol de la République
sur la lutte contre les idées
séparatistes extrémistes complotistes
d'autres pays l'ont fait citer l'exemple
du Royaume-Uni
notre pays le mettait en place depuis
plusieurs années depuis 2014-2015 et là
nous décidons de le faire je dirais
en grand ou de manière plus volontariste
avec un budget dédié et des partenaires
qu'on souhaite être plus nombreux
c'est je dirais nécessaire
à la fois pour mobiliser la société
civile et pour avoir une une parole qui
soit aussi mieux entendu par ce auquel
elle s'adresse parole qui porte pas le
label ministère de l'Intérieur quoi pour
le dire très clairement
si vous motorisez
chers collègues Breuillet puis ensuite
nous reviendrons vers le rapporteur
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur Monsieur le Préfet
j'ai deux questions est-ce imaginable
que Monsieur cifaoui
contacte cipdr en lui disant je sors du
cabinet de la ministre j'ai je vais être
subventionné pour participer à ce
discours
est-ce que c'est une initiative
imaginable par un de vos collaborateurs
que de dire à une personne m'a contacté
le cipdr on va vous soutenir je ne
comprends pas vous avez parlé de la
collégialité de la décision vous avez
évoqué que vous n'avez vu vous-même
monsieur cifaoui que le 22 avril mais
monsieur Gravel nous dit que Monsieur
Sifaoui est venu le voir en lui
indiquant que il allait être
subventionné
donc enfin c'est ma première question et
la deuxième c'est sur le contre discours
parce que moi je trouve intéressant
cette idée d'un contre discours on voit
bien que dans la jeunesse le discours
officiel parfois passe mal mais je ne
comprends pas j'ai le sentiment que il
est construit au hasard de rencontre
est-ce qu'il y a pas du côté du
ministère une analyse des ressources
disponibles des il y a des chercheurs
qui travaillent aussi en sciences
humaines surtout enfin est-ce qu'il y a
une analyse préalable avant de contacter
telle ou tel et lui proposer finalement
de rentrer dans ce bateau du contre
discours républicain dans ce navire de
la lutte contre l'islamisme radical
de réponse courte Monsieur le Préfet oui
il y a une nous mettons en place une
action pluie qui est nouvelle
qui n'a qui a peu de précédents et donc
on le fait en consultant des chercheurs
des intellectuels des journalistes des
scientifiques un certain nombre j'en ai
pas la liste avec moi mais je pourrais
vous les préciser au-delà de la au-delà
de l'audition pour réfléchir à la façon
dont les choses peuvent se mettre en
place au mieux
et nous recevons aussi des acteurs
associatifs
certains sont invités à formaliser un
projet il y a se rapprocher du CPL pour
aller sur une demande de subvention
et c'est ce qui se passe avec monsieur
cifaoui qui est reçu alors à une ou
plusieurs reprises sur une discussion
générale et qui vient au cabinet début
avril il est reçu par le cabinet et par
le cadrage du cipdr pour présenter le
projet illik oui
en termes verbaux et généraux
et Monsieur chiffoli sera invité par un
colorant du cabinet par mail à se
rapprocher du cipdr pour voir comment
déposer un dossier et à partir de là on
passe dans une phase qui est une phase
administrative
strictement
d'examens de sa demande d'instruction
puis de proposition
il n'est pris vis-à-vis de
la personne aucun engagement d'aucune
sorte
et même quand je le reçois le 22 avril
pour le compte de la ministre je ne
prends pas d'engagement financier dans
une phase administrative on attend
d'avoir un dossier d'avoir l'instruction
de ce dossier par l'administration
d'avoir une proposition de financement
par l'administration pour se prononcer
et ça on le fera je pense qu'on en parle
dans quelques instants en comité dit de
sélection le le
le 21 ou le 22 mai qui suivent
sur la deuxième question
qui concernait les compétences
pas de remarques particulières
on a consulté non mais on a on a
consulté on a construit on a consulté
très largement
y compris dans la phase de préparation
du projet de loi confortant les
principes de la République on a consulté
beaucoup d'acteurs scientifiques
culturels
administrative politique on a consulté
abondamment sur l'ensemble des sujets
dans la phase de préparation du projet
de loi
puis dans la réflexion autour de la mise
en place du contrôle républicain les
concessions ont été intenses et très
nombreuses et nous n'avons pas eu nous
n'avons pas eu de
proposition
on comprend bien Monsieur le Préfet la
vous le dites depuis ce matin ça nous a
été dit par d'autres la difficulté à
laquelle l'État est confronté
des annonces
ambitieuses et une difficulté le
discours institutionnel manifestement ne
passe pas et ou pas comme l'état le
souhaiterait et aller chercher des
partenaires notamment du monde
associatif mais je vous redis moi je
trouve qu'il y a une zone là il y a du
flou il y a du mélange bon alors je vais
essayer de rentrer de manière assez
méthodique dans le déroulement de la
procédure donc vous l'avez dit il y a
quelques instants et c'est repris dans
le rapport de Ligue 1 il y a il y aurait
donc eu deux réunions
lors desquelles monsieur Sifaoui dit
avoir
eu un échange au moins de salutations
avec la ministre
pouvez-vous donc nous nous confirmer
parce que ça a pas l'air d'être tout à
fait le cas et nous dire sur quoi dans
ces deux cas précis les échanges
emportés est-ce que déjà il était
question de la subvention oui ou non et
d'un montant oui ou non
alors
sur ces questions très précises mais sur
le rapporteur donc il y a eu un ou
plusieurs rendez-vous avec le cabinet de
la ministre pas au niveau du cabinet au
niveau du cabinet fin avril fin mars
début avril
pour évoquer
l'enjeu du contre du four de manière
générale et les monter une réflexion
collective et aussi dans un deuxième
temps
pour que monsieur seifoli présente le
projet hilaïque au cabinet au cpdr on
est donc début avril
cette proposition fait louer une demande
de subvention que je situe au 9 avril un
dossier déposé au cipdr le 9 avril le
projet hilaïque porté par l'association
us oppm
nous sommes amenés le 13 avril
en comité de programmation à examiner
plusieurs dossiers de demande de
subvention
instruit par par le cipda
il y a malheureusement peu vous l'avez
dit de trace de cette de ce comité
de ce qui s'est dit excusez-moi de vous
dire enfin je redis ici ma surprise de
voir sur un sujet comme celui-ci avec
les procédures vous l'avez dit notamment
menée par l'administration
l'absence de
compte-rendu de traces de dépôt enfin ça
va quand même là aussi dans la question
de la transparence sur un sujet comme
celui-ci en plus et vu porter sous les
feux de l'actualité en tous les cas dans
les annonces c'est
ça m'étonne
je comprends et je le partage nous
sommes dans une phase de mise en place
de structuration de ce processus
décisionnel et les choses vont
s'améliorer et se mettre en place
progressivement et à l'été et qui suit à
l'état 2020 sur un autre appel à
projetatif par exemple les choses ne se
passeront pas comme ça
plus formalisés et normalisé
et puis je vais continuer d'avancer
parce que
je peux pas comprendre ce que je
comprends pas votre réponse je sens
l'embarras la gêne mais vous pouvez pas
répondre à une question qui porte c'est
une réunion de mars 2021 en me disant
mais en 2020 ça c'est pas passé comme ça
si on tire les anciennes si on tire pas
ou si on fait l'inverse de ce qu'il
faudrait faire voilà ça donc je voudrais
juste reposer la question sur les
déclarations de Monsieur Sifaoui qui a
eu qui aurait eu plusieurs réunions donc
avec
vos services et dans deux d'entre elles
il aurait
salué la ministre et donc ce que vous
confirmez et deuxièmement quel a été le
contenu de l'échange à ce moment-là avec
Monsieur cifaoui
de dérouler le fil
pour le coup c'est moi qui pose la
question vous essayez d'y répondre je
vais après vous parler d'une réunion du
24 mars puis du 6 avril j'essaie de
prendre la chronologie puisque il vous a
pas échappé que ça fait un certain temps
qu'on travaille et on a besoin d'être
précis sur la chronologie qui est à dire
de à convenir ensemble un moment ça y
est on a ça on l'a traité de telle
manière voilà si vous voulez bien alors
je confirme ma réponse se présente
monsieur rapporteur la ministre n'a pas
rencontré ni reçu le monsieur Sifaoui le
22 avril à 15h15 je reçois pour le
compte de la ministre monsieur cifaoui
la ministre est passé le salué
cursivement elle ne sait pas attardée
elle ne sait pas assise elle l'a salué
cursivement
je vais revenir parce que c'est le 22
avril j'ai quelques
réunions avant donc il y a une réunion
qui se tient le 24 mars
en présence je me suis cifaoui du préfet
Gravel et plusieurs membres du cabinet
avez-vous participé à cette réunion et
pouvez-vous nous dire qu'elle était le
contenu le 24 mars
alors il y a eu une ou plusieurs
réunions au niveau des cabinets entre
pharmas et début avril je n'ai pas pour
ce qui concerne les dates précises de
ces réunions avec auxquelles je n'étais
pas auquel je n'étais pas
et il y a eu mon indiqué mes anciens
collaborateurs
au moins une réunion d'échanges
générales qui peut être celle de la fin
du mois de mars et une deuxième réunion
début avril de discussion sur un projet
présenté par Monsieur Sifaoui donc le D
donc vous n'étiez pas personnellement à
celle du 24 mars
il est fort probable qu'elle a eu lieu
c'est ce que vous dites probablement ce
qui est sûr d'ailleurs puisque ça nous a
été dit avec des membres de votre
cabinet
dont il n'est pas il n'y a pas de
compte-rendu il y a pas à votre
connaissance en tout cas c'est ce que
vous voulez déclarez deuxième temps le 6
avril en présence de Monsieur Sifaoui
toujours du préfet Gravel de monsieur
urdi qui est un des conseillers en
charge enfin le conseiller des relations
avec les élus et les collectivités donc
une réunion objet contenu des décisions
alors il y a une deuxième réunion très
certainement début avril sur le projet
illaïque présenté par par Monsieur
cifaoui je n'ai pas la composition de
cette réunion ce que je peux vous
indiquer c'est que le concile référent
sur le contrediscount et le fond
Marianne c'est le consier spécial de la
ministre et que les rencontres
écosystifaoui ont dû se faire à son
niveau à son niveau mais donc vous êtes
en train de me dire qu'en tant que chef
de cabinet
vous n'avez pas connaissance
de je dirais de ni du contenu ni parfois
même de la tenue des réunions enfin
c'est bien ce que vous venez de me dire
alors vous me parlez de faits qui sont
produits il y a plus de deux années
monsieur le rapporteur mais je sais bien
trace numérique il m'est difficile de
vous dire avec précision comment les
choses se sont déroulées à ces
moments-là je vous ai dit de manière
constante et à trois reprises déjà qu'il
y a eu un ou plusieurs rendez-vous au
niveau du kiné de la ministre
monsieur préfet j'entends mais vous êtes
chef de cabinet directeur de cabinet
pardon autant pour moi
vous avez donc la responsabilité
de l'organisation des temps d'échanges
sur un sujet qui est pas un sujet mineur
enfin
j'ai quand même enfin vous savez que
vous allez être auditionné
en général on va rechercher tout le
maximum d'éléments disponibles s'il y a
pas d'éléments disponibles
je continue de dire à ce stade sa
méthode
voilà dans d'autres auditions on a eu
des éléments très précis donc
voilà la question de la transparence
c'est de la parfaite connaissance
pour répondre à votre question
je vous le disais je suis au cabinet le
seul à disponible délégation de
signature de la ministre nous pouvons
imaginer une décision ministérielle il
n'y a pas eu sur ces rendez-vous
accordés à Monsieur Sifaoui de décision
de prise ou d'envisager autrement j'en
aurai été avisé j'aurais été sollicité
préalablement sur des audiences comme il
y en a comme ils s'en produit toutes les
semaines au cabinet qui n'ont pas de
mieux les décisions les décisions et
Monsieur cifaoui donc enfin lui EPM va
déposer un dossier de demande de
subvention je ne la trace dans un
tableau qui vous a été communiqué je
pense je le tiens à votre disposition
autrement monsieur rapporteur un tableau
qui suit le créneau de programmation du
13 avril
on voit que le projet déposé par l'ueppm
le 9 est abordé le 13 avril en comité de
programmation qui n'est pas validé qui
n'est pas validé et que le cabinet c'est
à dire votre serviteur
demande à ce que le projet soit affiné
qu'on
associe l'engagement du porteur de
projet à des indicateurs de résultats de
réalisation très très précis et on
renvoie sur l'appel à projets à venir
sur le fond Marianne l'examen de ce
projet qu'il en est de même pour les
autres projets déposés en matière de
contreditours numérique
je poursuis donc plusieurs réunions
entre la ministre cabinet monsieur
cifaoui qui était présent pour l'instant
il y a tout n'est pas concordant
est-ce que a été quand a été abordé
l'existence notamment pour Monsieur CIF
ah oui de l'usé ppm
quand avez-vous eu connaissance de
cette association donc moi j'ai
connaissance de s'association lorsqu'on
aborde la demande de subvention le 13
avril en comité de programmation
j'aurais l'occasion lorsque je reçois
monsieur siffle le 22 avril il vient
qu'une autre personne dont je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas le nom dans mon agenda il y
a pas l'occurrence il y a pas le nom de
la personne qui l'accompagne ils sont
deux sur ne pas la personne en question
visuellement il y a ce côté-là qui est
présent du cabinet et on aborde de
nouveau le portage associatif par
l'ueppn je prends note de ce qui me
présenter et je vais demander alors je
m'explicie c'est avant ou après mais je
vais demander expressément à ce qu'on
regarde
et à ce qu'on vérifie la le sérieux de
l'association en question qui
porte un nom et un objet social a priori
assez large
qui est parisienne ou local
et qui n'a pas été jusqu'à présent
accompagné par par le célibataire donc
je demande à ce que on vérifie que
l'association en question est à la fois
crédible et sérieuse donc vous dites que
vous
en connaissez l'existence seulement vous
en apprenez l'existence le 22 avril
je vous ai dit le 13 avril comme sa
programmation on aborde la demande de
subventions déposée par l'ueppm et le il
y avait une réunion avant le 9 avril
est-ce que des membres du cabinet
puisque il y avait le programme habituel
vous l'avez dit elle appelle à projet
est-ce que des membres du cabinet
avaient donc puisque c'est quand même ce
qui a été dit par certains
certaines des personnes additionnées
avaient envoyé des messages en disant
préparez-vous à répondre
quelle a été le rôle d'action soit du
cabinet ou la vôtre
alors l'appel à projet il est décidé
de l'organiser après ces rencontres avec
Monsieur siferoui ou d'autres on est on
est après on est après donc c'est après
le 22 avril non c'est avant après après
les réunions de début avril après on est
sur les questions monsieur on est sur
des questions qui sont extrêmement
précises et je l'entends qu'il faut une
information judiciaire
financier vous modifiez dans un cadre
qui est différent avec des questions qui
sont extrêmement précises sur lesquels
je n'ai pas avec moi les éléments de
documentation qui me serait nécessaire
je n'ai pas non plus d'appui d'un avocat
et il me paraît délicat d'être dans cet
exercice qui est légitime et auquel je
m'étonne complètement sans avoir des
garanties minimales de défense et de
protection
je j'entends votre ce que je vais
appeler une objection vous n'êtes pas
ici dans une procédure judiciaire vous
êtes vous le savez bien dans le cadre
d'une commission d'enquête et on essaie
simplement enfin moi j'essaie de à la
fois de comprendre et par la matérialité
des faits des rencontres puisqu'on a eu
comme on vous auditionne aujourd'hui on
a quand même reçu un certain nombre de
personnes qui nous ont donné de manière
très précise la chronologie vous
connaissez l'objet moi j'ai besoin de
nous avons besoin de comprendre la
matérialité la réalité des faits la
chronologie comment les choses et puis
vous l'avez bien compris il y a quand
même des enjeux
politiques certes mais là d'abord un
contrôle de l'action publique et des
dépenses qui sont engagées donc parait
pas inconvenant
ni déplacer de s'assurer que les
procédures
auquel l'administration dans toutes ces
exercices de ces responsabilités obéit
quelle que soit le cadre enfin donc
je vous sens un peu agacé et sur la
défensive il y a simplement une scène
curiosité et je le dis essayer d'avoir
des faits relativement enfin le plus
précis possible
je vais vous
je réponds aux questions que vous me
posez
pour ce qui concerne action qui a été la
mienne je vous le dis le 13 avril de
programmation nous met présenté ce
projet du lieu CPPM il n'est pas validé
le 13 avril et je retiens l'échange que
vous ayez la semaine sur la porter avec
le prix de l'Association vous dites au
président décision est prise de 13 avril
et le présent vous répond
je l'ignore il n'y a pas eu de décision
prise de 13 avril et aucun des futurs le
ras du fond Marianne ne sera avisé après
le 13 avril une décision leur faveur
j'insiste beaucoup sur ce point qui est
factuellement établi le 22 avril quand
je reçois monsieur cifaoui pour la
première fois pour ce qui me concerne
pour le compte de la ministre nous
échangeons sur le projet qu'il présente
je n'ai pas de souvenir précis de cet
entraîneur qui n'a pas joué d'un
compte-rendu mais ce que je peux assurer
c'est qu'il n'a pas eu d'engagement
financier de ma part et de la part de la
ministre sur le projet qu'il porte
et tous les échanges qui ont lieu sur le
projet sont menés par l'administration
par le cipdr de manière constante à
partir du dossier déposé le 9 avril je
vous comité de sélection le 22 mai
l'ensemble des échanges entre lieu et
ppm et le ministère sont conduits par
l'administration qui est dans son rôle
de réception d'un dossier d'instruction
de proposition d'un niveau de
financement le cabinet est dans le sien
dans l'impulsion préalable puis d'un
validation mais chacun est dans sa
responsabilité d'accord et c'était donc
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à l'issue
de cette entretien vous avez demandé au
secrétariat général du cpdr de mener
quelques investigations pour
comprendre quel était la réalité la
matérialité de l'association vous l'avez
dit son objet qui paraissait pas
forcément et naturellement spontanément
parfaitement approprié les les
renseignements que vous avez eu donc je
pense rapidement vous ont rassuré
et finalement conforté pour permettre
ensuite l'octroi de la subvention de
300.000 euros qui a été accordé
alors oui donc le 22 avril après cet
entretien je ne sais plus si c'est avant
ou après l'entretien je demande
expressément à mes collaborateurs à
l'administration de regarder de près ce
qu'est l'association en question pour
les raisons que je vous ai indiquées la
réponse peut apporter en comité de
sélection le 22 mai lorsqu'on aborde les
dossiers qui sont qui sont présentés
proposés par l'administration et ce que
j'en ai retenu c'est que la plantation
qui me faite est positive et qu'on me
met en avant le statut d'association
reconnue d'utilité publique de l'UEFA je
n'ai pas moi-même la capacité vous
l'imaginer de procéder des contrôles sur
des sujets comme celui-ci je fais
confiance à mon administration j'ai
passé consigne qu'on vérifie le point on
m'en fait un retour qui est positif je
considère que la réserve est levée
manifestement et au vu de ce qui se
passera par la suite
à regret mais la question que j'ai posée
a trouvé une réponse apporté qui est une
réponse positive voilà deux à ce stade
deux dernières questions qui touchent
plutôt au regard de d'autres
associations
est-ce que vous aviez des contacts avec
reconstruire le coma qui a également
obtenu
300.000 euros de subventions puisque
vous les aviez avant l'appel à projet
est-ce qu'il y a eu des temps d'échanges
de réunions
et si oui qu'elle a été un peu la teneur
de ces échanges alors pour reconstruire
le commun
il n'y a pas eu à ma connaissance
de rencontre ou d'échanges avec le
cabinet de la ministre
je ne connaissais pas l'association
moi-même et mes collaborateurs non plus
lorsque nous examinons la proposition de
demande de subvention le 22 mai en
comité de sélection
dernière question
c'est un peu la même avec d'autres
associations qui sont finalement
retenues puisque je le redis il y a
aussi un dialogue avec certaines
associations est-ce que vous aviez eu
des échanges préalables qui d'ailleurs
ont pu permettre de dire vous aurez
votre financement habituel
sous-entendu le fond Marianne c'est une
autre procédure
avec un arbitrage soit de les conserver
hors fond Marianne soit de les
rendre éligibles pour un projet soit
supplémentaire soit nouveau
au projet Marianne au fond Marianne oui
alors on est vraiment sur les
actionnaires
et on a
en 2021 très peu d'associations qui sont
sur ce terrain là avec des financements
du FIP des
très peu il y a deux phases qui se
chevauchent la première phase où on est
dans la posture de gragrée on cherche
des patins de associatifs on rencontre
on sollicite on démarche pour avoir des
projets qui émergent et un certain
nombre d'émerger avant lancement de
l'appel à projet
et l'appel approché du même qui
intervient après il y a des projets
déposés avant sur lequel nous ne prenons
pas de décision parce que
ces projets vocation à être versés dans
l'appel à projet et avoir leur demande
apprécié dans le cadre du Fonds
abordé sur l'appel à projet et le
rapporteur ensuite intervenant sur le
processus de sélection sur l'appel à
projet
d'abord il y a eu donc un appel à projet
qui a été réalisé à votre demande par le
cipdr est-ce que le cabinet modifié cet
appel à projet ou à souhaiter y amener
des indications particulières et si oui
lesquels oui alors il y a le 13 avril je
demande à l'administration de proposer
un texte pour l'appel à projet qui nous
est communiqué assez rapidement il y a
un échange entre le cabinet et
l'administration sur le texte lui-même
des modifications qui sont apportées
notamment sur le calendrier
nous sommes dans une des délais qui sont
courts je reconnais je l'assume bien
volontiers dans un contexte qui est
celui d'une menace terroriste qui se
situe un niveau extrêmement élevé
au mois d'avril 2021 nous avons la
Transat terroriste de Rambouillet
commissaire de Rambouillet le 23 avril
on est sur contexte là et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président de votre
conférence initiale ce sont des éléments
qui sont très importants de
circonstances exceptionnelle qui
explique et justifie me semble-t-il les
démarches et les délais très
volontariste qui ont été qui ont été
retenus
nous prévoyons d'avoir trois semaines du
20 avril au 10 mai pour le dépôt des
dossiers de candidature
avec
le souci de retirer des projets qui
soient opérationnels murs et prédéma je
crois que le texte de la police dans le
45 jours qui suivent l'identification de
la subvention
j'exprime par ailleurs au cipdr la
priorité l'accord de la ministre à cet
appel à projet fond Marianne donc une
demande de mobilisation qui est faite à
notre administration
et si c'est délai son cours c'est vrai
ils n'en sont pas moins tenables et nous
aurons sur ce pas de temps de trois
semaines plus de 70 dossiers qui vont
être déposés ce qui montre que des
acteurs associatifs et tout à fait en
capacité de répondre dans l'urgence sur
l'appel à projet qui était le nôtre
oui tout d'abord je vous avais encore
accéléré par rapport à ce qui était le
premier projet le premier projet c'était
finalement un déroulé entre le 1er mai
et le 30 juin et sur votre demande il y
a une accélération c'est à dire c'est
ramener à fin mai début juin donc
effectivement il y a un système
d'accélération j'entends et on partage
le fait qu'il faut toujours se mettre en
mémoire du temps dans lequel on est il y
a pas il y a pas de doute là-dessus en
même temps
quoi qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs votre
présentation initiale le disait le fond
Marianne n'est qu'un élément particulier
c'est pas la création du fond Marianne
et de mise en route le truc qui va être
de nature à contrer un risque un risque
immédiat donc c'est plutôt je crois très
clairement une
comment dire une communication que le
gouvernement veut positive sur le fait
qu'il agit bon voilà
et j'allais dire que c'est quelque chose
qu'on assez régulièrement quand il y a
un problème
un incident dans le cas précis un
attentat il y a toujours une volonté de
pouvoir afficher une réponse une réponse
rapide malheureusement on a vu et vous
l'avez dit puisque vous avez dit
malheureusement etc c'est que ça induit
effectivement des manques de
surveillance ça induit dans le choix des
partenaires manque un peu de vigilance
puisqu'on va vite et on repère pas
effectivement que l'association par
exemple en question dont on parle de ce
sont qui a jamais dépassé 50000 euros de
chiffre de budget annuel bon donc quand
elle demande elle-même pour la première
fois 600.000 euros puisque on est on est
à cette à ce niveau au départ la
première demande initiale bon on voit
bien qu'on est hors-jeu complet par
rapport à la capacité à faire surtout
dans un système financé par l'État ou le
financement le si bien arrive toujours à
quelques mois de retard il faut pouvoir
porter l'action pendant quelques temps
donc cette accélération du système n'a
pas n'est pas toujours
très très propice vous nous dites que
vous allez être à l'origine mais il y a
sans doute dans ce délai contraint
beaucoup de réseau finalement de
d'arriver à des soucis par la suite et
d'ailleurs si vous aviez aujourd'hui un
peu à froid si je puis dire les choses
de à vous poser la question de ce délai
est-ce que vous répondriez vraiment que
vous venez de le faire en disant
finalement dans 73 projets mais en
réalité vous avez pas eu 73 de projets
vous avez quelques projets significatifs
et des tout petits projets si vous
voulez quelques milliers d'euros ou
dizaines de milliers d'euros on est sur
des choses beaucoup plus modestes et en
fait vous avez quatre associations qui
prennent deux tiers des montants et
c'est bien ces quatre associations sur
lesquelles vous appuyez en priorité
de avec lesquels vous avez une habitude
de travail aussi PDR et de nouvelles qui
sont donc désignés dans l'urgence et cet
aspect là nous paraît important est-ce
que si vous aviez à le refaire
aujourd'hui vous diriez non ben on a eu
des réponses et ça marche quoi
le contexte est important parce que on
est dans cette obligation ardente d'agir
et on le fait dans tous les domaines
la plateforme Pharo c'est le renforcer
en l'espace de deux mois une telle
construire un républicain la mise en
place en l'espace de quelques semaines
le pot national contre la haine en ligne
au sein du parquet de Paris il est créé
en janvier 2021 le projet de loi
confortant le respect de la République
il est présenté sur la posture d'urgence
au Parlement on est dans cette urgence
cette honte obligation qui oblige à
aller vite
avoir plus de temps aurait été
préférable je vous l'accorde je pense
qu'on aurait pas forcément pris trois
mois clairement mais un délai de 30 à 45
jours aurait été un délai je dirais
normal et raisonnable dans les
circonstances exceptionnelles que nous
connaissons au printemps 2021 nous
sommes sur 20 jours c'est un délai qui
est court mais ce n'est pas non plus un
délai qui est intenable j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus ce n'était pas un
délai
[Musique]
qui sont aujourd'hui clarifiés pour tout
le monde on voit bien que c'est pas au
système que ça de se lancer avec des
budgets considérables à l'échelle des
associations bien entendu les budgets
considérables sur des projets qui ne
connaissent pas et sur lequel il faut
tout inventer en admettant qui s'est eu
la volonté réelle de
d'avancer donc en tout état de cause
voilà c'est un échange que je demande
pas d'avis vous avez donné le vôtre mais
on peut dire que c'est pas tout à fait
couronné de succès alors
maintenant vous avez eu vous l'avez
expliqué on le comprend bien vous avez
donc vous avez fait une commande
politique c'est exactement le terme qui
a fait Christian Gravel mais tout à fait
légitimement le cabinet est là pour ça
pour faire de la de la commande
politique à son administration donc ça
il y a pas de il y a pas de sujet
vous faites une commande politique
administration qui a un délai très court
qui vous souhaitez nous dit-on trois
mois pour pouvoir le faire
de manière plus plus élaborée qui le
fait très rapidement et qui le fait très
rapidement auprès de gens que finalement
on pourra aller chercher une nouvelle
action parce qu'il s'agit de ça il
s'agit de faire des choses différentes
il s'agit pas de prolonger des actions
passées mais pour faire des choses
différentes et bien vous allez chercher
vous
vous cabinet je prends large bien
entendu pas partie de personnel mais
vous cabinet ministre vous allez
chercher
Mohamed chifaoui qui lui-même ramène si
je puis dire l'association en question
parce qu'il faut passer par une
association parce que vous ne pouvez pas
le financer directement en tant que je
ne sais quoi expert cabinet conseil etc
vous pouvez pas donc vous le faites à
travers une association sur lequel les
précautions minimales ne sont pas prises
même si on a entendu votre position qui
est de dire votre administration vous a
sécurisé sur ce point mais c'est bien la
réalité qui ressort qui ressort du
dossier et de l'autre côté une craie une
création ex nihilo de gens qui ont un
projet qui qui défendent leurs idées qui
sont conformes à l'esprit de ce que vous
souhaitez mettre en place et sur lequel
il y a des problématiques d'autres
natures il y a du travail qui est
réalisé mais des problèmes d'autres
natures sur lesquelles on reviendra mais
d'une certaine façon en faisant un délai
court finalement on interdit en réalité
de nouveaux projets d'arriver ne peuvent
arriver que des projets qui arrivent
soit qui arrive par le haut si je puis
dire soit par vous soit par Monsieur
gravelle qui avait monté qui avait déjà
cette vision de cette association
reconstruire le commun et donc ces deux
projets
sont dans les tuyaux je simplifie et
arrive si vous voulez le fond Marianne
et il rentre voilà donc de précision à
la réalité que vous avez présenté ce
sont vos termes qu'on vous dites vous
allez chercher monsieur cifaoui dans le
vous
qui le dit pardon d'accord il dit que le
cabinet l'appeler la joie vérifiera
sincèrement qui nous confirme les choses
dont le vous et je vous le disais dès le
début de l'audition et si les consignes
que j'avais passé dans ces rencontres
auditions avec les uns les autres pour
alimenter la réfection collective je
souhaitais que les acteurs soient reçus
conjointement par le cabinet par
l'administration il n'y a pas de
dichotomie les choses se font ensemble
donc le vous est à vous qui est très
collectif
et quand vous dites c'est parce que nous
dit Monsieur Ravel
monsieur Gravel nous dit c'est pas un
vocollectif monsieur Gravel nous dit
Monsieur Sifaoui nous a appelé pour nous
dire qu'il rentrait sur fond Marianne
qu'il avait vu la ministre qu'il avait
croisé le cabinet on verra avec lui
enfin
il nous dit bien que ce projet lui est
arrivé il est pas arrivé par le cabinet
qui en discute avec lui il est arrivé
par Monsieur Sifaoui c'est pour ça que
je me permets je crois que la Formation
Judiciaire
déterminera la façon le jeu se sont
passées véritablement et précisément moi
ce que je leur disposition c'est que la
consigne que j'avais passé c'est que les
acteurs soient reçus conjointement par
le cabinet par l'administration son qui
est de dichotomie entre les uns les
autres
et le projet qui est présenté par l'uepn
n'est pas un projet que le cabinet et
moi-même sommes allés chercher nous
l'avons réceptionné ce dossier il est
arrivé d'ailleurs au cipdr
le point est important d'accord on va
venir donc
c'est pas un dossier
la demande initiale de l'use es e ppm
portait vous savez sur une période
triannale d'un million et demi d'euros
soit pour 2021 635
000 euros
lors du comité de programmation qui
s'est tenu le 13 avril
en même temps que la réunion de
coordination
il avait été décidé d'accorder à cette
association une subvention de 300000
euros qui finalement le 21 mai vous
l'avez dit lors du comité de sélection
se rapportait à
355000 euros
est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire je
vais y venir assez précisément ce qui a
motivé
les modifications donc quels étaient les
organisnements initiaux que vous dont
vous aviez éventuellement connaissance
de la ministre et de votre cabinet et ou
de votre cabinet vis-à-vis de Monsieur
Sifaoui et ce qui correspondait à la
demande initiale de 635000 euros pour
l'année 2021
pour quelle raison la subvention a été
baissée à 300.000 euros et ce qui a eu
entre le 13 avril et le 21 mai en dehors
du 22 avril ou vous rencontrez monsieur
cifaoui d'autres temps d'échanges avec
qui monsieur
cifaoui le Président Monsieur Karuna
Garand finalement qu'est-ce qui a
modifié
ce parcours 635000 devenu 300 000 et
finissant à 600 à 335 000 pardon 55
alors le 13 avril en comité de
programmation monsieur rapporteur on a
plusieurs dossiers qui nous sont
présentés par par l'administration dont
celui de l'ueppm pour 635.000 euros il
n'y a pas de décision de prise de
programmation il n'y a aucun engagement
ni avant ni après qui soit pris formulée
ou indiqué a lieu ce ppm par le cabinet
et je crois aussi par l'administration
des choses sont très claires
et le 13 avril
ce qui
se discutent sur s'association ce sont
les points un niveau de financement qui
est
élevé sans rapport avec nos possibilités
surtout une association aussi récente
des engagements de réalisation qui
doivent être précisé et un projet qui a
été déposé quatre jours
préalablement et qui mérite d'être
affinés entre l'administration et le el
porteur de projet donc il n'y a pas de
décision de prise pour l'USBM le 13
avril de programmation si je crois ce
que vous indiquez la semaine dernière le
prénom le superbe tailleur il n'est pas
connaissance de ce que une formation de
trésorerie il n'y a pas des session
prise
il y aura à partir de là des échanges
avec lieu ce ppm qui seront le fait
exclusif de l'administration dans son
travail sa mission de gestion de l'appel
à projet d'examens des candidatures et
le dialogue avec les porteurs de projets
et le projet revient le 22 mai lors du
comité dit de sélection où nous
examinons les propositions que formules
l'administration pour choisir les
lauréats du fond Marianne
la proposition qui est faite il y a pour
ce comité de sélection une note de
proposition qui est datée du 20 mai qui
a été préparé par par le cipdr je pense
que vous en avez communication sinon je
la tiens à votre à votre disposition à
la fois une note de couverture et une
note plus complète sur les laurés qui
sont proposés à invalidation et lors du
commissariatisation le 22 mai pour ce
qui est lieu ce ppm
le cabinet votre serviteur valide la
proposition qui est faite par
l'administration sur un niveau de
financement à 355000 euros pour l'ueppm
avec une réponse qui n'est que verbale
par ailleurs à la demande de
vérification que j'ai formulé
précédemment d'accord alors il y a un
article de Libération de juin de cette
année 2023
dans lequel il est pressé que l'ancien
ministre délégué madame Schiappa aurait
présenté au journaliste un mail daté du
6 février 2021 adressé au cabinet
indiquant que la subvention accordée à
me sur cifaoui lui semblait excessive
elle aurait donc écrit précisément dans
ce mail
30000 euros de l'État ça me paraît
énorme ici est-ce que vous confirmez
cette information puisqu'il vous a pas
échappé que la date du 6 février 2021 ne
correspond pas aux dates à la
chronologie des événements tels que nous
l'avons encore
tel que nous avons échangé jusqu'à
maintenant est-ce que il avait donc déjà
été évoqué une subvention au moins par
la ministre antérieurement aux dates que
vous venez de nous donner alors aussi
sérieux ça me paraît totalement
impossible
il n'y a pas de projet
déposé envisagé par Monsieur Belem ou
son principal porteur à cette date là je
ne sais pas à quoi ça peut faire
référence on est sur des heures monsieur
le rappeurs
qui font vivre nos formations judiciaire
avec des investigations qui portent sur
l'ucpm qui vont conduire à des auditions
il m'est difficile de vous répondre dans
ce format de la commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur des faits qui font
l'objet de sa formation judiciaire de
manière aussi précise je m'en excuse
mais ça me paraît pas compatible
je suis je vais juste vous faire une
proposition si à l'issue de l'audition
vous êtes en capacité de ce qui me
paraît possible a priori de nous
communiquer des éléments complémentaires
factuels de chronologie nous les
recevrons bien volontiers voilà
merci Monsieur
la ministre a priori devait présider le
comité de sélection ça n'a pas été le
cas finalement vous en connaissez les
raisons
il était prévu que le 22 mai
lors de la reine du comité sélection à
10 heures le 22 mai la ministre vienne
ouvrir la Réunion
et qu'il y ait une action de
communication sur la réunion du comité
de sélection qui marque l'arrivée à bon
port de l'appel à projet fondmorial pour
des raisons que je n'ai plus à l'esprit
la ministre n'a
pas de souvenir qu'elle soit passée et
les partisans cette réunion vont dans
son sens également la ministre n'a pas
ouvert la réunion et j'ai été amené à la
présidé du début jusqu'à la fin pour son
compte d'accord il n'y a pas eu de gris
de notation
il y a pas eu de relevés de décision
particulière
il y avait des raisons alors nous avons
en entrée de réunion cette note datée du
20 mai
produite par par l'administration et
nous aurons en sortie de comité une note
du 31 mai qui
recense les décisions prises sur sur le
fond Marianne
cette réunion
je la préside elle va durer
[Musique]
sans doute autour d'une heure et demie
et nous allons valider presque
intégralement les propositions faites
par l'administration quant à la fois au
choix de l'orea et au niveau de
financement qu'il aurait réservé la note
préparatoire fait état de 71 dossiers
déposés
71 dossiers déposés dont
47 qui sont qui sont éligibles
24 ont été écartés sur un critère
territorial parce que ce sont des
projets qui n'ont pas d'envergure
nationale ou intérêts plusieurs régions
départements qui a sur 601 aussi à
déposés pardon 24 qui sont écartés par
le cipdr au stade de la de la
recevabilité je dirais
le passage de 47 dossiers éligibles
à 22 qui sont présentés dans notre
préparatoire n'est pas explicité il
n'est pas explicité
je pense que ça peut tenir
à la nature des actions proposées on
souhaite avoir des actions en ligne
exclusivement et puis contre le discours
qui ne soit pas les actions numériques
et puis ça tient certainement au fait
qu'on a raisonnement sous enveloppe il y
a 2 millions 500 000 euros disponibles
pour le contre discours sociétal
avec les 22 dossiers qui sont
priorisés par le seapelaire on est déjà
au-dessus de son offre disponible il
était je dirais
de mon point de vue il était attendu et
normal que le cipdr opère ce travail
d'instruction de présélection et de
priorisation
finalement vous avez travaillé enfin
dans un temps très contraint
je dirais même assez court
j'en conclus de ce que vous nous dites
que vous avez privilégié l'analyse
peut-être à la consignation des de
certains éléments permettant de
finalement d'expliciter les montants
enfin tous les cas de les motiver ce qui
veut dire que vous avez procédé de
quelle manière avec les associations qui
n'ont pas été retenues vous les avez
informés avec
une procédure particulière une lettre de
pas de suite une formule plus ou moins
comment dirais soit lapidaire soit très
administrative
dans une dans une démarche ou les
responsabilités qui fait quoi entre
l'administration du cabinet était
clairement répartis la phase encore une
fois d'instruction et de mise en
administrative c'est le CIP d'ailleurs
le cabinet était là pour impulser puis
pour pour valider d'ailleurs ce que une
programmation de sélection PORTE un
terme qui n'est pas forcément décoite ça
a été un comité de validation à quelques
amonisations près par rapport aux
propositions faites par l'administration
que j'ai endossé à le valider à l'issue
du comité
il était nous étions convenus
de ne pas rendre public la liste de
leuréat le point a été discuté était
discuté nous avons arrêté ce choix
parce qu'il nous paraissait pas pardon
c'est pas la question parce qu'on a déjà
eu ce type de réponse la question c'est
juste de savoir si dans les réponses les
associations non retenues ont été
informés entre guillemets sous quelle
forme et sous quel délai c'est pas
d'accord alors il était une étions
convenu qu'il y ait un courrier de la
ministre aux associations retenues
lauréate
ce qui a été je crois fait j'en ai pas
trace dans mes archives numériques mais
je pense que ça a été fait en tout cas
plusieurs ont témoignés jusqu'à présent
dans le cadre de votre commission il
était convenu que l'administration
notifie au candidats non retenu le fait
qu'il n'était pas l'orée du fort moyen
donc l'administration sur laquelle vous
aviez aussi une influence a dû faire
mais vous n'êtes pas sûr alors le cpdr
c'est prononcé c'était prononcé pour
accorder une subvention de 100.000 euros
à une association qui en avait
d'ailleurs soluté 140 000
je dis bien le cpdr c'était prononcé
pour mais sur une décision du cabinet
donc il doit y avoir un lien avec vous
l'association n'a finalement rien obtenu
est-ce que vous pouvez
vous en expliquer les raisons est-ce que
vous avez le souvenir de cette décision
j'ai pas beaucoup d'éléments factueux à
ma disposition et je n'ai pas de
souvenir précis des échanges en comité
de sélection qui remontent à plus de
deux années
si on a une réunion du Nord d'une heure
trente le souvenir que j'ai et
évidemment dont je dispose me permettent
de dire ou de vous redire que les
propositions faites par l'administration
ont été presque intégralement validés et
que entre les notes du préparatoire et
de sortie du comité j'ai relevé très peu
de différences
ma question à ce point est dans la
question du rapporteur en fait c'est que
comme pour tous les dossiers pour cette
association là il y a une note préalable
du CI PDR et que le 20 mai au comité de
sélection cette association est retenue
et que par contre il semblerait
que par mail d'un membre de votre
cabinet le 2 juin le financement soit
retiré
ce qui voudrait dire
pour poser la question autrement qu'il y
a eu
un comité de sélection
qu'à l'issue de ce comité de sélection
il y a
il y a une proposition qui sort
qui est faite par ce comité de sélection
et que dans les jours qui suivent
il y a encore des modifications qui se
font hors comité de sélection si je puis
dire par le cabinet
là dessus nous avons reçu un mail très
clair pour montrer qu'il y avait eu une
sortie d'une association après le comité
de sélection et alors que cette
association avait été retenue est-ce que
vous pouvez est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire si c'est la réalité ou la
réalité on a les mails bon
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça c'est à
dire l'idée que finalement il y a un
appel à projet on en a parlé il y a un
comité de sélection on en a parlé mais
que le comité de sélection finalement
n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga et n'est
pas la fin de l'histoire et que dans les
jours qui suivent il y a encore des
modifications sur ce dossier est-ce que
vous pouvez nous confirmer ce point
alors
en comité de sélection le 22 mai nous
entrons en réunion avec une note du
célibataire qui propose 15 dossiers qui
propose 15 dossiers à à validation
et qui en annexe cet autre qui sont qui
sont
proposés
pour pour discussion
sur ces sept projets sur les 15 projets
liste principale je crois qu'on comité
de sélection nous les validons
presque tous à l'exception d'un seul qui
sera capable après discussion parce
qu'il est considéré que les actions
proposées sont des actions qui sont
intéressantes pertinentes les porteurs
du projet sont par ailleurs d'une grande
qualité mais on est sur des
interventions en milieu scolaire qui ne
sont pas les actions de conditions
numériques cette action est écartée pour
cette région là sur les 7 associations
qui figurent dans l'annexe et donc ils
font une discussion particulière en
comité de sélection il y en a trois qui
vont être retenues
en tant que lauréat à des niveaux de
financement qui sont inférieurs à ce qui
était demandé pour des raisons
d'enveloppes budgétaires
il y a une association
qui de cette quatrième association de la
liste annexe qui n'est donc pas proposé
par le cipdr en financement au titre du
fond Marianne on n'est pas dans liste
principale et qui dans l'échange qu'on
peut avoir au cours du comité puisque
c'est un échange de la collégialité
je pose des questions mes collaborateurs
aussi les le cipdr il y a un secrétaire
général ses collaborateurs il y a une
discussion collective et sur cette
association que vous citez avec une
demande à 140 000 euros le comité de
sélection dans les conclusions que Jean
dresse à l'issue du comité est retenu
pour un montant de 100.000 euros
cette liste de lauréats naturellement je
rencontre à la ministre pour lui faire
part des décisions qui sont envisagées
et nous avons sur cette association
une réserve de la de la ministre en
raison d'un historique de relations
assez ancien et par ailleurs dans les
jours qui précèdent ou qui suivent à la
fin du mois de mai
une mise en cause par WordPress de d'un
membre de l'association vis-à-vis de la
ministre ce qui conditionnit sur ce
point qui était un point de discussion
important en comité de sélection et qui
relevait d'une d'un arbitrage ou d'une
confirmation par la mite nous avons une
décision de
non-sélections sur cette association
donc il y a bien eu sur les décisions
arrêtant comme outil sélection pour l'un
de ces lauréat une affirmation par
le montant qui est consacré aux actions
de contre discours numérique
et au fond Marianne il y a
une association qui va être retenue
avant le lancement du fond Marianne sur
un projet déposé depuis déjà plusieurs
mois un projet qui est prêt à démarrer
et qui va être financé sur une partie
des crédits de leur mariage on est sur
le contreditours numérique sociétal 2
millions 500 000 euros 2 millions seront
attribués dans le cadre de l'appel
approché du fond Marianne et 500.000
euros l'auront été hors appel à projet
et avant lancement de l'appel à projet
pour une association qui porte un projet
très important
et prêt démarré alors j'ai
une avant-dernière question là j'ai un
vrai problème puisque dans le rapport de
là vous venez d'évoquer une question que
vous aviez évoquée avec la ministre qui
a tranché
et d'un rapport de l'IGA il est
mentionné que
la ministre délégué
ce serait effacé du processus une fois
passé
le lancement de l'appel à projet le 20
avril vous venez de dire que le 22 mai
à l'issue du comité de sélection vous
avez eu une discussion et d'ailleurs une
décision de la ministre ou venez de le
dire donc c'est en contradiction je le
porte à votre connaissance si vous
souhaitez vous exprimer évidemment vous
pouvez le faire avec les éléments
qui sont portés au compte-rendu de du
rapport de l'igéa
la ministre
a lancé le fond Marianne le 20 avril
elle à l'occasion d'une d'un entretien
et d'une interview en presse le jour où
l'appel à projet est lancé par ailleurs
par le cpdr de manière formelle et
administrative la ministre se tient
effectivement à l'écart du processus
elle ne rencontre pas de porteurs de
projet elle ne participent pas au comité
de sélection le 22 mai elle ne donne pas
l'instruction
particulière
collective ou individuels sur le choix
des lauréats et il y a en communauté de
sélection cette discussion qui est une
discussion
importante sur l'association que vous
avez cité puisque l'administration ne
propose pas de la financer
et que en sortie du comité en tant que
président de la Réunion l'association on
enviage de la financier donc il y a bien
un point de discussion particulier sur
l'association qui n'est pas proposée par
l'administration spontanément que le
comité soit président retient et c'est
un point que je porte à l'arbitrage de
la ministre
et sur ce point-là elle fait connaître
son arbitrage qui est un arbitrage
défavorable
ma dernière question
certaines associations donc ont vu vous
l'avez dit leur subventions
réduites vous avez évoqué une il y a une
association bibliothèque sans frontières
qui
a obtenu donc à peu près la moitié de ce
qu'elle sollicitait 70 000 euros alors
qu'elle se listait 130 000 je mets ça en
rapport avec
la subvention dont elle avait bénéficié
l'année antérieure qui était de 140 000
euros vous avez
des quelques éléments pour éclairer
notre lanterne
alors abonnez-vous sur l'importer
clairement non moi j'étais dans un une
approche on va dire stratégique j'entre
à ce comité avec une préparatoire qui
donne des éléments pas forcément tout
l'historique et nous appuyons sur
l'administration pour faire ce
travail-là je rappelle c'est important
nous avions donc créé l'unité de
contredit il faudra républicain au sein
du cipdr fin 2020 en avril 2021 l'unité
compte 15 agents et nous faisons
confiance à notre administration dans
des relations de confiance et alors que
nous avons veillé à ce qu'elle soit
renforcée pour faire ce travail
d'instruction de priorisation ce qu'elle
a fait a priori
Alma qui est une association bien connue
avec
laquelle les le système institutionnel
travail n'a finalement pas été
comptabilisé dans le fond Marianne
quand bien même plusieurs documents
indiquent et attestent dans un je dirais
dans un premier temps quel a été retenue
dans le cadre du fond vous avez une
explication sur ce revirement
alors l'association que vous avez cité
dans les documents qui vous ont été
communiqués pour le comité de sélection
il est je crois à mentionner
expressément que
la décision a été prise
[Musique]
préalablement et or appel à projet et le
trésorerie en comité de programmation me
semble-t-il on est sur un projet qui
était déposé je crois en début d'année
début février auprès du célibataire un
projet de média en ligne en direction
des jeunes dans les dans les quartiers
populaires
un projet très travaillé moi j'ai eu
l'occasion bien avant c'était à
l'automne 2020 de recevoir le directeur
de l'association et plusieurs de ses
collaborateurs
avec le secrétaire du cipdr et puis du
cabinet pour que le projet ne soit
présenté le projet paraissait très
ambitieux et pertinent il est déposé en
demande de subvention début février et
nous décidons de le valider les prêts à
démarrer nous le validons aura pas la
projet début avril
grâce au crédit que nous ont pu
mobiliser pour le contreditours sociétal
c'est à dire de 1500 000 euros on est
hors appel à projet ce qui montre bien
qu'il y a bien deux phases distinctes la
phase de grains et Greg il y a une
association qui sera choisie dans cette
phase là sur un projet déposé très
entraînement aux autres puis une phase
d'appel à projet sur laquelle seront
envoyés tous les autres projets déposés
plus précocément ou après des rencontres
avec le cabinet d'accord ce qui doit
vous le dire ce qui n'a pas empêché la
ministre d'adresser
un courrier de félicitations à cette
association
qu'elle a signé
avec une mention manuscrite précisant
quel était L'Oréal de du fond Marianne
oui il y a pu y avoir une effectivement
c'est une norme matérielle ou une
confusion qui s'explique par le fait
qu'on est sur le contredit discours
numérique on est sur
ce budget de 1900 000 euros
et l'association que vous avez cité
et financer grâce à ces crédits-là et
sera suivi comme les 17 lauréats du fond
Marianne de manière plus importante
quant aux réalisations qu'elle fera
vous dites c'est une confusion je dirais
de manière permettez-moi de dire c'est
pour le moins particulièrement confus
dans le dans le fonctionnement
une dernière question
est-ce que puisque ça a été évoqué il y
a quand même deux associations
qui sont pointés une première l'uspm qui
a un budget de fonctionnement habituel
relativement faible qui n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec la cause
nationale que vous mettez en œuvre au
travers du fond Marianne qui voilà d'un
budget annuel de 50.000 euros de
fonctionnement
sollicitent un million cinq sur trois
ans on l'a évoqué une deuxième qui n'a
pas d'existence propre qui se crée et à
laquelle
des fonds importants de 300.000 euros
sont
vont être accordés
je dirais dans le comité puisque vous
évoquez la rigueur du comité de
sélection
vous pensez que rien n'a échappé à votre
la vigilance et à la rigueur du travail
tant de l'administration que du cabinet
alors
aujourd'hui la réponse
est claire au vu du rapport Ligia publié
hier soir au vu de ce que l'on sait la
réponse est claire
il y a deux ans dans le contexte que
vous connaissez d'urgence attentat
mobilisation générale nous avions des
projet qui était présenté qui ont été
instruits appréciés par une
administration
professionnelle renforcée spécifiquement
pour pour cela et quand on prend ses
décisions lors du sélection le 22 mai on
le fait avec un niveau de sécurité
pour ce qui est du cabinet qui est un
niveau
important LV alors nonobstant nonobstant
monsieur le rapporteur nous allons tenir
alors que c'est pas forcément d'ailleurs
la mission du cabinet a opéré un suivi
précis à opérer un suivi de l'action de
ces de ce lauréat et je vais provoquer
une réunion de suivi le 14 décembre donc
six mois après la sélection des projets
pour regarder vérifier
puisque j'entends ce que vous dites un
niveau élevé de sécurité mais vous dire
juste avant regarder fait maintenant on
s'aperçoit que
il y a pour le moins
une marge une erreur ce que je veux
quand même vous dire à nos collègues a
eu l'occasion lors d'une audition
présente de rappeler que
dans le fonctionnement habituel des
associations des attributions de
subventions notamment lorsqu'elles
sollicitent les collectivités parfois
pour des montants de quelques centaines
d'euros pour demande des éléments de
bilan et là vous nous dites avec comment
dirais-je gravité au regard de l'urgence
une association qui n'a pas d'existence
propre
présente une demande de 300.000 euros
urgence de la situation frapper fort
association en cours de création contre
discours républicain
il y a on délivre comment dirais-je un
bon à tirer je veux dire comme ça de
300.000 euros et il y a pas plus de
questions au regard de la gravité et de
la situation de son importance et des du
sérieux du comité de sélection
dans la fonction qui était la mienne à
l'époque sur le travail et les
propositions qui sont
faits par l'administration
je n'ai que ces éléments là
d'appréciation
clairement
Monsieur le Préfet simplement conclure
cette phase
on n'arrive pas à être très convaincu
vous le sentez
sur sur ce sujet là et on arrive pas à
être convaincu pourquoi parce que en
aucun cas le fond Marianne n'est une
réponse appropriée à un risque
d'attentat c'est une action
que l'on peut imaginer qui peut avoir du
sens
mais qui est une action de long terme et
qui se construit dans le long terme avec
une idée de profiter finalement d'un
reste à réaliser pour démarrer une
action mais avec l'idée d'ailleurs c'est
même dans les objectifs dans les
objectifs dans le cahier des charges il
y a l'idée qu'il faut trouver des
cofinancements la notion est évoquée
clairement des co-financement pour
pouvoir perdurer faire perdre du respect
d'action dans le temps on le comprend
bien et donc sa sœur à cette question de
vitesse non la question de la vitesse
c'est la question de la rapidité de la
communication
c'est c'est tout le problème de la
nécessité supposée de devoir répondre
vite à l'opinion publique sur des sujets
aussi importants et aussi graves et
quand on regarde finalement
quand on regarde les choses entre
finalement la façon dont l'appel à
projet c'est fait la façon dont on a
préparé en amont quelques associations y
compris des créations pour pouvoir
répondre à cet appel de à cet appel à
projet quand on voit comment se fait la
sélection quand on voit qu'après
finalement
la réunion de sélection les choses
bougent encore qu'il y a des
associations qui sont retirées que
d'autres voient leur niveau BC etc
l'ensemble de tout ça permet de dire que
la remarque de l'IGA l'appel à projet
n'a été ni transparent ni équitable
reste d'actualité et je pense qu'il
qu'à l'avenir il faudra tirer de cette
expérience ce qui s'est fait là quelques
règles pour l'avenir je viens d'un mot
il est maintenant tard je viens d'un mot
sur le suivi de la réalisation des
projets
d'abord mais vous avez déjà ouvert cette
voie sur l'idée que le cabinet avait
participé au suivi de la réalisation des
projets
c'est une question qui était qui était
posée qui n'apparaît pas directement
dans le dossier et est-ce que finalement
la procédure de suivi était la même que
pour les autres subventions FIP et
je pense par exemple précisément votre
question
d'apporter
une remarque sur
le constat qui est posé par rapport déjà
que vous avez que vous avez cité il
transport en équitable j'ai pas d'Asie
personnel juste faire remarquer que
concrètement sur le contredischronique
nous avions deux possibilités l'appel à
projet ou le gré à gré et que entre les
deux la procédure qui présente un niveau
de transparence et d'équité
plus favorable c'est l'appel à projet
vous l'avez bien expliqué vous aurez pu
procéder différemment et faire de gras
gré
nous n'aurions pas ces critiques là
aujourd'hui qui sont fondées très simple
pour certains mais nous aurons pu faire
différemment et le fait de choisir
l'appel à projet n'a pas été fait pour
refuser la transparence et l'équité bien
au contraire
on peut bien sûr discuter ensuite du
résultat et je suis là pour pour ça oui
mais là c'est la notion de est-ce qu'il
y aurait une intention de c'est parce
que nous indiquons nous sommes factuels
simplement nous parlons pas d'intention
de pas sur ce registre
sur la question donc
de la procédure de suivi est-ce qu'elle
est identique à celle du FIP des
classiques sur le suivi on est sur une
phase qui relève de la responsabilité
de l'administration classiquement à la
fois pour formaliser une décision de
financement via un acte attributif
arrêté ou convention attributive de
subventions
en respectant les règles qui sont
prévues à cet effet le cas échéant en
revenant vers le cabinet s'il y a des
difficultés ou des écarts ou des
modifications à apporter très
classiquement et puis un suivi sur
l'impact on est sur une action publique
qui est nouvelle encore une fois
des montants qui sont significatifs pour
certains
un besoin de démontrer l'impact de ces
nouvelles actions et donc contrairement
à ce que nous faisons pour les personnes
nationaux classiques le cabinet demande
au cpdr avec une tête de contredours
nouvellement créé d'assurer un suivi un
suivi
fin un suivi des réalisations et c'est
dans ce contexte là que je provoque une
réunion de suivi le 14 décembre
2021 qui sera pressé d'une autre
préparatoire produite par le site du 13
je pense que vous l'avez sinon je peux
tout simplement vous la vous la
communiquez et cette note comme les
échanges qui ont lieu en comité enfin
réunion de suivi ne laisse apparaître ne
laisse pas apparaître d'alerte
ou de discuter particulière la tonalité
est positive
y compris sur l'ueppm donc on sera le
commun il est fait mention d'un décalage
pour certaines associations dont
celle-ci
du calendrier de réalisation qu'on peut
comprendre à ce stade de six mois après
là les décisions en comité de sélection
et il ne met pas fait état de
difficultés où ils ont comment d'alerte
sur l'action des 17 lorés du fond Brian
plus l'association qui est si rattachée
comme sur le rapporteur le zéro marqué
précédemment et ce sera le cas jusqu'à
mon départ du cabinet début 2022 où je
n'aurai pas d'alerte ni en interne ni
venant de l'extérieur sur des
difficultés et l'action de l'Orée du
fond moyen je crois que ça va être le
cas jusqu'au terme du mandat de Marlène
Schiappa au ministère de l'Intérieur
merci
[Musique]
alors vous avez écouté j'imagine où vous
avez relu les auditions de certaines
associations
qui ont un site qui avait qui nous ont
dit des choses donc qui sont compliquées
toujours sur le lien entre un ministère
et des associations par rapport à une
subvention surtout que c'est subventions
on l'a vu en fait des la totalité quoi
des projets elles ont été montées
souvent ça a été des projets montés avec
l'idée qu'il y avait des co-financeurs
qui pouvaient être publiques ou privés
dans la réalité les co-financeurs on
peut le comprendre d'ailleurs c'est
compliqué à trouver sur ces thèmes là et
donc du coup c'est 100% ministère de
l'intérieur mais c'est on a des phrases
du type
on ne souhaite pas être des on ne peut
pas être considéré comme des
prestataires de services du ministère de
l'intérieur
alors cette relation entre ce qui paye
au monde et
et l'autonomie d'un système associatif
ça paraît assez fin à toucher
un commentaire
oui
notamment dans le suivi je veux dire la
relation du coup le suivi porte sur quoi
s'il porte pas sur en dehors de l'aspect
financier on oublie il y a un contrôleur
il est là pour vérifier les factures etc
ça on oublie donc parlons du contrôle de
l'exécution
comment vous voyez un contrôle
d'exécution
utile vous n'êtes pas alerté d'ailleurs
par quoi que ce soit alors qu'il y a des
choses à dire c'est au moins on le
découvre aujourd'hui
alors on n'est pas sur une prestation de
service on est sur un projet associatif
c'est très important un projet
associatif dont les termes et les
engagements n'ont pas été
dictés ou commander par l'administration
ou le ministère très important on est
sur un projet associatif en réponse à un
appel à projet qui fixe des grands
objectifs un cadre mais le projet se
suivait de l'association
dans cette relation entre l'association
et l'administration ou le ministère
moi ce qui me paraît important c'est que
il y a des engagements qui soient précis
de réalisation un qu'on sache ce qu'on
finance et c'est sur ces éléments là
même s'ils sont succinctement présentés
en comité de sélection on va se
prononcer quand au choix de le rat au
niveau de financement
après on a aussi sur quelques principes
généraux qui valent sans qu'on ait
besoin de les préciser et dans ces
principes euros il y a la neutralité
la partialité
de l'action publique et il n'est pas
concevable c'est une ligne rouge absolue
que sur fond public on puisse
soutien des actions qui s'insèrent dans
le débat politique ou démocratique je
fais référence à ce qui est reprochait à
une association parmi 17 du fond
Marianne très clairement c'est une ligne
rouge absolue que nous avons fixée et
qui vaut dans tous les cas de manière
générale de ne pas intervenir avec le
contrediscours républicain dans le champ
électoral ou démocratique et ça vaut
pourquoi juste pourquoi il n'y a-t-il
alors qu'il y a des
signalements en tout cas des
interrogations au niveau du cpdr je ne
sais pas si elles sont remontées jusqu'à
vous vous allez nous le dire mais
pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas une mise en
garde
autre chorale je veux dire on a une
relation contractuelle avec une
association il y a une difficulté de
cette nature qui apparaît vous en citer
une on écrit c'est même totalement je
veux dire c'est immédiat on écrit on
relate le problème et on demande une
réponse voilà bon pourquoi il y a rien
on a l'impression que tout glisse vous
voyez ce que je veux dire on peut on
peut éventuellement pointer des choses
encore que les associations en question
ne l'ont pas même entre bien entendu
voilà mais en plus on ne leur écrit pas
et donc aujourd'hui quand on leur dit
mais attendez
les gens tombent voilà tombe de la
chaise jamais écrit alors ça peut être
effectivement compris comme une règle
générale de bon sens ça de ce point de
vue là je suis d'accord avec vous mais
lorsqu'on constate un dysfonctionnement
et qu'on est financeur est-ce que ça
mérite pas
un petit écrit
une règle générale
qui vaut absolument pour
l'administration et donc pour nos
services et pour le CPL
rouge pas d'interférence et c'est
important on est sur un champ de
contrediscours qui est un champ
qui relève du débat public qui peut
facilement entrer en résonance avec le
débat politique donc on est sur un champ
où la ligne rouge c'est de ne pas
prendre part à des discussions des
débats de nature et électorale ou
démocratique et donc pourquoi on écrit
pas ça je ne saurais pas vous le dire
moi je n'ai pas d'alerte particulière
lorsque je suis en responsabilité de
cette nature et d'ailleurs d'aucune
autre je crois qu'il n'y en aura pas non
plus
jusqu'à ce que la ministre délégué
quitte ce ministère délégué au mois
d'avril on met 2022
mais ce sont des débordements qui ne
paraissaient sans réaction et d'ailleurs
je crois qu'il y a des tu crois qu'il y
a des réactions me semble-t-il si j'ai
bien écouté les auditions des
précédentes
oui enfin c'est pas il y a pas le même
son si vous voulez côté associatif et
côté
cpdr mais bon nous verrons nous
poursuivons parce que leur avance et
donc il faut il faut conclure et puis
pour tous si je puis dire donc
on lance alors avec tambour et trompette
pression est un peu forte mais on lance
avec une grande force se font Marianne
je pense que la ministre est à peu près
sur tous les plateaux de télévision le
même soir elle passe de leur à l'autre
il y a en tout cas si la ministre est là
pour faire de la communication c'est
pour porter le message si je veux le
redis positivement du gouvernement en
terme de réaction bon donc on a ça et
puis ensuite finalement
puisqu'on est sur un label de
communication mais cela même de
communication il ne sert plus c'est à
dire qu'on en reparle plus
quasiment il y a une réunion qui est
préparée pour novembre 2022 normalement
qui doit se tenir alors nous dit que
c'était peut-être même à l'Élysée que
c'était prévu mais on n'en sais rien on
a entendu ça bon mais en tout cas l'idée
qu'en novembre 2022 il y a un petit
point d'étape qui soit fait finalement
il n'est pas tenu 22 ou 21 monsieur le
Président et on me dit 22 mais
c'est donc pas sur votre
sur votre sur votre sujet mais il peut y
avoir une vérification à faire dans
notre point de vue mais elle n'a pas
lieu
c'est peut-être novembre 21 quand même
un peu de truc mais je ne sais pas donc
on va on va vérifier ce point de mais en
tout cas ce qu'on peut constater sans
même parler de cette réunion
c'est que il n'y a plus de communication
sur le fond mariage plus de son plus
d'image si je puis dire sur est-ce que
on en est comment les choses se mettent
en place quel résultat enfin on peut
imaginer que quand on lance une idée
forte par rapport à un événement
monstrueux par ailleurs et qui reste
dans les mémoires de tous pour ça que
c'est pour ça que cette affaire pour
Marianne
est tellement sensible c'est que elle
porte sur un sujet enfin il y a un lien
qui est fait entre un sujet extrêmement
grave et le font mal et donc il y a une
attention à ce qui se passe et là plus
de son plus d'image sur ce sujet plus de
médiatisation
plus de résultats c'est bien 2021 comme
vous l'imaginiez comme corrige sur un
instant et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi on en
parle plus est-ce que finalement vous
avez enfin je vais pas répondre à votre
place
je pourrais pas me prononcer sur ce qui
s'est passé après mon départ je le
comprends mais un cabinet on est en
novembre 21
et mon arrivée
il y avait sur le fond Marianne une
initiative une impulsion qui a été
donnée par la ministre avec des projets
nombreux qui ont été déposés
par des associations qui étaient déjà
connues d'autres qui n'étaient pas du
tout une grande diversité un grand
pluralisme d'acteurs
nous n'avons pas
plus avec les lauréats
organisé puisque cela d'initiative ou de
communication parce qu'on a tenu à
protéger ne pas exposer ses lauréat il y
a ne pas les marquer d'un soutien de
l'État pour l'efficacité de leur action
donc il y a pas eu de communication
particulière et l'objectif de fond ça
reste sur une action publique qui se met
en place nouvellement de l'inscrire dans
la durée
de faire en sorte que cette action se
s’inscrive dans la durée et ce pérennise
et ce normalisent donc le fond moyen
c'est un fond d'impulsion d'amorçage en
2021 et l'enjeu était qu'à compter 2022
est né suivantes ces actions de
contreditours numérique fassent partir
des actions conventionnelles de droit
commun soutenu par l'administration
ministère intérieur
très bien vous nous avez pas vous
répondre le président au-delà de mon
départ sur ce qui a oui je comprends
bien je comprends mais vous nous avez
répondu sur le fait que vous n'aviez pas
été alerté jusqu'à votre départ de
problèmes particuliers notamment sur les
deux associations question mais
peut-être éventuellement sur d'autres je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
peut-être une petite d'abord une
première remarque sur le sujet de la de
la communication rien n'empêcher
de faire comment dirais-je des actions
de communication puisqu'elles
s'inscrivait dans l'appel à projet du
fond Marianne
et je veux revenir sur pour être bien
sûr
de la clarification du sujet entre le
cipdr le cabinet sous votre autorité et
la ministre vous confirmez bien que
c'est le cpdr qui a préparé l'ensemble
car aucun moment le cabinet n'est
intervenu sur la préparation et je
dirais sur le les associations qui ont
fait partie du de la sélection qui a été
proposée le dans le comité du 22 mai
c'est bien ça on est sur on est sur
répartition des rôles qui est bien
celle-ci avec un cabinet qui pour le
compte de la ministre impulse
répercute la commande ministérielle va
en comité de sélection validé
de propositions pour certaines une
administration qui réceptionne les
dossiers de demande de subventions les
instruits échange avec les porteurs de
projet priorise et propose un niveau de
financement il y a quand même donc il y
a une zone j'ai envie dire il y a une
zone de flou entre
la publication définitive et le comité
dit de sélection dont vous avez dit mais
vous n'êtes pas le seul à l'avoir dit
qu'il était un comité de validation
et en fait ensuite il y a quand même
comment dirais-je
une intervention politique vous en avez
évoqué une deux trois enfin alors je
sais pas si c'est à chaque fois la
ministre parce qu'entre les montants qui
sont pas ceux qui sont plus faibles que
se demander
où
finalement une proposition validée non
retenue après change avec la ministre
si vous avez je dirais des dernières des
derniers éléments
précis à nous communiquer soit tout de
suite soit par écrit je vous le dis nous
serons preneurs nous sommes preneurs
puisqu'on on a quand même la volonté
d'avoir une présentation et pour je
pense que pour tout le monde et
notamment au regard de l'action publique
et je le dis
je pense que on a qu'à ma climat
politique qui est lourd on est sur un
fait Claude Raynal l'a déjà dit on le
dit régulièrement le fait générateur est
quand même un acte d'une barbarie son
nom des annonces fortes sur des valeurs
fortes et malheureusement aujourd'hui
dans
ce qu'on est amené à examiner montre
qu'il y a du tout à l'heure c'est pour
le moins confus je vais pas aller plus
loin parce que s'agit pas de tirer
activement de conclusion
merci c'est vrai que l'absence de
formalisation des échanges et des
décisions dans des documents
rédiger et signé et pénalisant pour
retranscrire le processus et différentes
étapes et les décisions prises c'est une
vraie difficulté
et l'essentiel de ce qui vous est
rapporté repose sur les témoignages les
souvenirs les échanges entre les uns et
les autres c'est pas toujours toujours
simple ce qui fait fois me semble-t-il
ce sont les décisions qui ont été prises
et formalisées dans les attributifs
de subventions par l'administration
après échange avec le cabinet de la de
la ministre je confirme ce que je vous
ai dit précédemment le comité de
sélection a pour l'essentiel valider les
propositions faites par l'administration
après instruction sur dossier des vrais
dossiers déposés par les porteurs de
projets il y a eu quelques amies
en comité de sélection
sur la liste complémentaire et il y a eu
un dossier que vous avez évoqué de la
liste complémentaire que le comtitution
a remis en liste principale et qui a été
portée la brioche de la ministre sur ce
seul dossier là c'est ce que je peux
vous dire et c'est ce que j'ai réussi à
retracer après beaucoup de recherches
après beaucoup de recherches et de
consultation des uns des autres pour
comprendre précisément une chose se sont
passées mais oui je crois que
on va évidemment se maintenir là nous
avons deux questions des collègues on va
les prendre et une réponse très brève et
des questions brèves Isabelle briquet
puis philippe Dominati non
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Préfet vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure il y a eu 71 dossiers une
sélection très importante certaines
associations écartées travaillaient déjà
de longue date avec le cipdr si monsieur
cifaoui était connu du Cid PDR
l'isepm était inconnue par contre
du Cid PPE du Cid
r je sais plus
donc n'avait visiblement jamais fait de
demande de subvention mais de n'importe
quel subvention subventions quelle
qu'elle puisse être ces dernières années
et avait un budget cela a été dit un
budget moyen de 50 000 euros vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure qu'il s'agit bien
de projets associatifs
et lors des échanges évoqués aussi à
l'instant entre monsieur Sifaoui et le
cabinet échange particulier puisque ce
n'a pas été le cas pour d'autres
associations le fait que l'uppppm
[Musique]
ne travaillez pas sur le sujet traité
demande en première intention une
subvention ce que ça a été dit tout à
l'heure ça a été réduit cette subvention
était réduite par la suite mais faisons
12 fois sont son budget
n'a pas soulevé quelques interrogation
que ce soit de la part du du cabinet
merci
philippe Dominati vous prendrez les deux
questions pour conclure je voulais
compléter la question que poser le
rapporteur général parce qu'il y a cette
notion de cabinet mais je croyais que le
cabinet était assez léger dans
l'organisation et par les décrets du
Premier ministre alors ça concerne
combien de personnes parce que c'est une
notion un peu collective
et j'aimerais savoir combien de
personnes au cabinet s'occupaient du
fond Marianne parce que si c'est 15
personnes c'est évidemment pas la même
chose que de deux trois décideurs et
deuxièmement il y a le relationnel
effectivement dans le fonctionnement
d'un cabinet tout le monde le sait qu'il
y a entre l'autorité ministérielle et la
délégation que l'on fournit au cabinet
et quelle est cette part comme le
souligner le rapporteur général qui a
été faite on a eu des exemples dans le
passé au ministère des Finances ou le
directeur de cabinet était investi de
pouvoir pour mieux
les plages du ministre pour prendre des
décisions
c'est une question qui mériterait d'être
un petit peu souligné monsieur le
Président
ce président
le cabinet a reçu
la personne qui a été cité à plusieurs
reprises et non pas l'association
ce n'est que la personne qu'elle sait
plusieurs robuste qui a été reçue par le
cabinet
cette personne là à plusieurs reprises
ce n'est pas lieu ce ppm
qui ne sera pas reçu au cabinet et avec
laquelle il n'y aura pas de relation
particulière qu'elle soit téléphonique
par mail ou autre de la part du cabinet
et quand je reçois le 22 avril
la personne qui a été citée pour le
compte de la ministre c'est bien la
personne que je reçois et pas
l'association voilà l'association l'uspm
elle n'a pas été reçue elle a été gérée
intégralement par l'administration à
partir du dépôt demande de subventions
et cette demande
je ne rends pas pour argent comptant
puisque vous avez rappelé le montant qui
était demandé initialement 635000 euros
et que
dès la première présentation de ce
projet donc le 13 avril en comité de
programmation on marque des réserves
immédiatement
on demande à ce que le projet soit
affiné donc revu avec le porteur de
projet
au vu d'engagement qui peuvent être pris
et au vu de vérification opérée sur le
statut de l'association donc vis-à-vis
de cette association on a été dans une
approche qui était une approche
rationnelle
prudente et on a parlé pour argent
comptant ce qui était demandé par
l'association en question très
clairement et ensuite c'était géré par
l'administration
pour répondre à la question de monsieur
le sénateur
sur combien de personnes au cabinet est
en charge du fond Marianne
aucune spécifiquement il n'y ait pas un
conseiller fond Marianne du tout
c'est un sujet le contrediscours qui
était suivi en termes de portefeuille de
compétences des uns des autres par le
conseiller spécial de la ministre sur
une partie de son temps partie très
minoritaire et par le conseiller
prévention de la délinquance c'est des
actes à la citoyenneté et promotion de
la citoyenneté sur une partie aussi très
minérale de son temps donc deux
conseillers principalement à mes côtés
c'était pas un sujet secondaire ou
périphérique du tout pour les raisons
qui ont été rappelées et j'attache une
égal importance à tous les sujets tous
les chantiers que la ministre avait en
responsabilité mais c'est
un chantier qui une fois passé la phase
d'impulsion
et la validation relevée pour
l'essentiel de mission administrative de
préparation et d'exécution
et quant à la porte de délégation
question effectivement centrale un parti
dans les cabinistériels je dirais que
c'est fonctions
ces fonctions des relations de confiance
entre le ou la ministre et son sa
directeur de cabinet
j'avais la mise pourra sans doute vous
l’indiquer j'avais au sein du cabinet
une délégation de signature j'étais le
seul en bénéficier et donc j'étais le
seul collaborateur qui était fondé à
engager
vis-à-vis de l'administration vis-à-vis
des tiers des décisions de la ministre
et je rendais compte bien évidemment de
toutes les décisions importantes de
manière régulière permanente à la
ministre
pour ce que j'étais amené à dire ou à
faire en son nom
merci merci Monsieur le Préfet nous
avons passé ensemble deux heures et
demie
ce qui nous a permis je crois de voir
effectivement l'ensemble des points des
sujets qui posent question dans ce fond
Marianne merci encore merci monsieur